안녕하십니까. 채물 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리
모닝브리입니다.
오늘은 7월 10일 금요일입니다.
1부 시작하겠습니다.
전일 중국 시장도 반등이 있었는지
우리 왕부장님과 함께 알아보겠습니다.
>> 네. 어제는 진짜 그 예배로 시전을
되게 강하게 올라왔습니다.
>> 아 중국이요?네 네 맞아요. 테크축
급등하면서 상수 플러스 1.25%
올라왔고요. 흥승 체크 지수는 그냥
보수 나왔습니다. 정시 과대면 이정
구조한까지 올라왔습니다. 업종별
부제는 IT 커뮤니케이션 헬스케어
관련 업종이 강세였고 밤면에 필수
소비제 수업제 부동이 약세되었습니다.
그 CXMT 상장 1년 대충
나왔어요. 이분다 말 성장
예정입니다. 대충는 23일부터
28일까지 이종하 하루에 성장할
예정입니다.이
소식으로 반도체 군수 다 급등했어요.
어 부파장은 9% 가까이
올라왔습니다. 거의 10% 상한가
기준까지 올라고 조유태그 10%
상한가 종미 반도체는 11.5% 5%
올라고 스 4%
전전 테크는 10% 상한가 전 테크는
18% 종으로 다등했어요.
>> 사풍기는 충구 대규모 영산등 소식으로
관령주도 상승했습니다. 한국기는
8.5% 6% 항공 정보는 6%
SMC는 14% 화전세 12% 다
극동했습니다.
2분기 10조 하쪽 그리고 센서분기
추가 개선등 기대으로 서버 관련주
어제도 오라고요. 인스퍼 어제는 그냥
리서치 하는 회사이고 어제 10%
상한가 기로했습니다. 이외는 그음
관연주
어 공업 불량은 또 거의 5%
올라왔어요. 음.
>> 음. 그다음에 저가 매수 자극
요입으로 PCB CC와 관련주도
가능했습니다. 승인 테크는 8%
올라고 동산률 10% 선단도 10%
호전시 7% 올라왔어요. 2분기
허실적 기다금으로 광동시 관련주
어제도 급등했습니다. 정제 우선은
5.9% 신역선는 7% 천부동시는
10% 선상했습니다. 한편은 2차
증지 권용주 어제도 반등하고요.
CT는 4% 이모 에너지도 4%
올라왔어요.
>> 음
>> 반면에 페 소비체 등 방어주들이 어제
조절 받았고요. 신념물 구체 금리
어제 염정 2bp 상승됩니다. 인연물
구체 금리는 염정 4b 하라고 외양화
확 환율는 염정 2%
절상되었습니다.음
>> 감사합니다.
>> 위에 지수 보니까 어저께 말씀 주신
것처럼 상해 지수도 1.65% 상승
>> CSA 300 그러니까 중국에서 가장
[콧방귀] 우량하다고 해야 될까요?
시가 총액이 크다고 해야 될까요? 그
코스피 200코스피 200
>> 2.5% 창업은 더 많이 오르고
그랬는데
>> 맞습니다.
>> 우리 선전 지수는 어떤 특징이
있어요?
>> 아 [한숨] 선전 지수요?
어 그렇게 생각할 수 지수는 아 약간
뭐 이미 많이 박었어요. 상하 지수는
대충 다오 지수 생각할 수 있고 쓰는
지수는 그냥
나스타 [웃음]
약간 지금은 그 지수는 변화가 좀
많이 생겼어요. 그래서 단순히
예전보다는
좀 다르게 나오고 있습니다. 머릿속에
어 중국의 나스닥은 창업 뭐 이렇게
좀 전되어 있는데 그 선전 지수가
약간 캐릭터가 [콧방귀] 좀
모호해졌나 봐요.
>> 네. 그 신진 지수는 나스타
생각하면은 창업하는 나스타 대
>> 딱 그런 느낌이 있어요.
>> 아 그러면 창업판에 상장되어 있는
기술주들이 선전 지수에 상장되어 있는
기술주보다 시가 총액이 더 커요.
>> 음. 네. 그렇게 그렇구나. 그러면
머릿속에는 일단 상해 지수는 다우.
네.
>> CSI 300은 어 SMP 500
또는 코스피 100.
>> 음. 네.
>> 그리고 선전 지수는 나스닥.
>> 창업하는 나스닥 100백.
>> 네. 제가 옛날 생각으로 하면은
이렇게 나올 수 있어요. 왜냐면이
6MT잖아요. 그리고 MTC
>> 그 연습 메모리 그리고 창시 메모리
상정하면은 다 상하 지수로
평임합니다.
>> 상하 지수.
>> 그래서이 고조는 완전 그 다 변화.
그러면 상해지액 상위의 어떤 업정별,
배분, 비중 이런 것들도 좀 변화가
많이 있겠네.
>> 음. 그럼 이제 상위 지수를 추종하는
혹시 ETF 같은 것들을 뭐
퇴직연금이나 어 개인 투자를 하고
계신 분들이 계시다면
>> 훨씬 더 탄력이 생길 수도
있겠습니다.
>> 네. 맞습니다.
>> 이해했습니다. 어
CXMT 얘기 잠깐만 그 하고
넘어갈게요. 제가 그냥 얼핏 듣기로는
한국에서는 개인이 사기는 어렵다.
>> 아 살 수 없다고 생각하시면 되고요.
기관은 대부분은 살 수 없다고 생각할
수 있습니다.
>> 음. 그러면 만약에 CXMT에 대한
장기 성장성을 보고 관심 있는 한국
내 투자자라면
>> CSMT를 포함하게 될 ETF를
찾아보는 수밖에 없을까요? 음,
맞습니다. 다만 그 섹스 MT 바로
선장하자마자 지수 편입 못 했잖아요.
>> 그래서 차도 되게 애매해합니다. 그건
나중에 [목을 가다듬음] 편입하면은
사셔도 괜찮고요. 사면은 과천 ETF
있어요. 과창 이름 표시하는 ETF
있어요.
>> 아니면 CXMT MTC 무조건 과창반
들어가니까 예, 맞아요. 과창 ETF
사시면 됩니다.
>> 음. 알겠습니다. 세트에 대해서는
조금 더 상장 스케줄이나 시가 총액
이런 것들은 조금 더 여쭤 볼게요.
다
>> 네.
>> 오늘은 어 CAT의 로만인 거
같습니다.
>> 네. 시티어는 거듭사스 그 커버
리포트 나왔어요. 아마 그 담당
에너지도 바꿔서 그러는데 뭐 되게
리포트 깊게 나왔습니다. 뭐 C티
지금 시가 총는 368조원 정도
됐고요. 포드 P는 16 18배 정도
아 15배 정도가 내려갔습니다.
그러면 그러면 2차 증지 시장 MS는
40%쯤 되고 충구 시장 MS는
47% 1등 유지하고 있고요. 충구
내수는 70% 해외는 30% 그렇게
보시면 됩니다.
>> 1분이 실적 거의 전에 나왔습니다.
매출는 동기 대비 52% 건설 13%
상후에 수익는 동의 49% 건설
18% 성후했습니다.
>> 1분기는 출화는 동일 대비 60%을
증가했어요. 이중 2차 전기 출화는
동일 대비 50% 출량은 동일 대비
80% 정도 증가했어요. 전반 그
ESS 출화량 기준으로는 비중을
25%까지 올라왔어요.
지문 2차 정지 GP 마티는
23%부터 25% 수준을 유지하고
있고 ES GP 마지 25% 28%
수준을 유지하고 있습니다. 어 여기서
잘 보시면음
2분기는 컨서스 있어요. 대충 지금
보는 컨스 기준은 230억이
정도예요. 그래서 2분기 실존은
이보다 높게 나오면은 그냥 서프레즈
푸시면 되고요. Q 10% 정도 증가
예상 3분기는 Q도 추가적으로 20%
4분기도 15%부터 20% 증가
예상입니다. 그래서 연간을 환상하면은
1,억이 정도 나올 수 있어요.
전에는 아마 지난달 리퍼드풀 봤을
때는 연간은 980% 정도 보고
있어요. 그래서이 컨서스는 계속
우라하고 있습니다.
>> 공급 부조에 따라서 추라 목표치도
상승 가능성이고요. 간 컨서스는
1000GW 가지고 올라왔습니다. 어
건너만스 리퍼즈 보면은 배터리
업체에서 에너지 솔루션 업체로
전화하고 밸루에 재핑가 필요한다고
얘기했어요.
>> 지금은 셀 판매 업체에서 시스템
플러스 서비스로 차원 모델을 정환되고
있습니다. 그래서 마진이 2는 개선
예상입니다.
>> ES 사업은 화자에 따라서 ESGP
마진이 27%에서 30%
이상을까지화될 가능성이 있고요.
마진도 동기대 마진도 기준이
있는데보다 45% 선승 가능성이
있습니다.
>> 특히는 중국 ES 시장 구조에 따라서
MS는 20%에서 2030년에
40%까지 하될 가능성이 있어요.
전기차 배터리 시전도 회복되고
있습니다. 중국 이웨이 배터리는
2025년부터 2030년까지 추경
시즌 17% 정도 추정되었고요.
MS는 45%에서 50%까지 후입부
예선입니다. 따라서 어 원래부터 내년
내 훈년 매출에는 동기 대비 가가
44% 19% 10% 증가 예상이고
EPS는 가까가 27% 23% 증가
주정되었습니다.
파견는 전기차 배터리 차부 어 11배
2비다로 적용하고 ES 사업 차부는
18배 2달로 적용했어요. 그래서
DP는 50 55 외로 제시했습니다.
어제 전가 대비 대충 50% 없애
나올 수 있어요. 감사합니다. 어,
CATL은 워낙에 어, 시가 총액
자체도 400조원 가까이 되고
>> 어, 전 세계 2차전지 1등 업체가
된지 워낙 오래돼서
>> 어, 저는 궁금한 점이
>> 어, 원래는 이제 자동차양, 전기차향
어, 배터리가 시작이 됐겠습니다만
지금은 추가적인 전방 산업으로 ESS
산업용 또는 기업용
>> 어,이 배터리 시장으로 진출을 하는
어, 2차전지 회사들이 생겼는데
>> CATL은 당연히 ESS까지 까지
이제 전부 다 하고 있습니다.
>> 그리고 전 세계 1등이고 중국
1등이고.
>> 네.
>> 어 그래서 사업 모델에 있어서
부정적인 변화가 있다거나 어 의미
있는 경쟁자가 생겼다거나 그런 건
아닌 거 같아요.
>> 네. 그런데 밑에 보면 어 PRV
PBR 밸루에이션이 과거 보다 이렇게
쭉 밑으로 하향 조정되면서 어
여태까지 보여줬던 어떤 밸류에이션
밴드 하단에 거의 붙어 있거든요.
>> 그러면 어 그냥 일차적으로 업항이 안
좋은가?음 음. 그러면
>> 그런 생각을 첫 번째 하게 되고 두
번째는 매니지먼트가 어 좀 지리
그니까 퀄리티가 좀 안 좋아졌나 뭐
이런 이차적인 생각도 해 보게 되는데
큰 틀에서 어떻게 이해하고 넘어가면
될까요? 아 그 만 원에 이게 훨씬는
배터리 뭐 글로벌 1등 있잖아요.
줄로 그 2차 전지 자동차 용터
배터리를 만들었어요. 충분는 지금 그
짐투류는 이미 50% 넘어갔어요.
그냥 뭐 길거리 뭐 보는 거 자동차
대부분은 다 전기차요. 중구 시장
보면 다만 충구 시장 빼면 헤비
시장에 되게 애매해요. 아직도 내형
개차 전기차는 좀 섞어서 가고
있잖아요. 그리고 미국 정부는도 계속
뭐 보정뭐 뭐 주겠다고 그냥
추석하다고 계속 반복되고 있으니까
해외 시현지 인류는 생각보다 그렇게
빠르지 빠르게 우라하지 못했어요.
그래서이 2차 정지 수요 전노에 대한
우려가는 크고요.
>> 아 저희가 보통 얘기하는 마켓 그로스
>> 맞아요.음
>> 현재 영유하고 있는 산업 내에서의
산업 성장성 둔화
>> 맞습니다.
>> 그래서이 부분은이 2차 증지 배터리
때문에이 회사는 시가총을 4배조
정도가 받았어요. 빨리 이렇게
받았어요. 다만 지금 쭉 핵심
포인트인데 ES 시장도 봐야 합니다.
지금 ES 시장은 25% 정도가
차지하고 있잖아요. 아직도 그냥 2차
전지보다는 매우 낮은 수준에요.
나중에는 2030년까지는 2차 청지
50% ES 50%는 그렇게 구조 밟
수 있어요. 제가 개인 생각했을 때는
ES 찍 쪽으로는 편관을 잘
받으면은이 시가총에 따부 나올 수
있을 가능성이 있어요. 왜냐면 ES는
우리 순가대로는 뭐가 뭐 에너지 저축
있잖아요. 그런데 es를 제일 많이
쓰는 데는 데이터 센터예요. 데이터
센터.
>> 그래서 지난번이 컨쿨 때는이 호사는
처음으로 언급했어요.
>> 1기가 [목을 가다듬음]
데이터 센터는 그냥 약간 15부터
20기를 기가 왔듯이 그 ES를 했던
돼요.
>> 음. 음.
>> 그래서 이렇게 지금은 전체 전세 그
데이터 센터 그 수주 그리고 브로체
합성하면은 대충 ES도 수요년
3,000보다 4,000바식 정도
해요.
>> 그러면 역사를 하면은 이거 4배 좀
넘어가는 시장이다.
>> 음. 말씀을 쭉 들어 보니까 전기차
시장에 대한 시장의 성장성 회복
기대는 별로 없으신 거 같고
>> 네.
S
밸루에이션을 좀 높이는 이벤트 총매가
될 것 같다라는 말씀을 주셨는데
>> 네.
뭐 근 없습니다만 [콧방귀] 조금
기다려야 되나 그런 생각이 들었어요.
만 지금 버드 비아는 18배
있잖아요. 아 18배 15배
전체잖아요. 그래서 이거는 ES
쪽으로 아직도 핑가 받지 못하는
상황하고 있습니다.
>> 그뭐 자동차 승장승는 CG는 또
17% 잡으니까 그러면 17배 정도
받아야 되고요. 뭐 단순 그 2차
정지 배터리 2차 시장 그렇게
생각하시면 되고 그 ES 쪽으로
승장성 훨씬 더 높게 나오고 있으니까
그래서이 멀티블은 최소는 20에 아마
30 이상을 받아야 되고요.
>> 그래서 지금 사고 좀 뭐 기다리면
되지 않을까 싶고요. 왜냐면 글로벌
이등이니까.
>> 네. 어, 직국께 좀 물어봤던 이유가
어, 워낙에 지금 이제 싸져 있는
상황에서 이제 다운사이드, 그러니까
주식을 샀는데 손실을 볼 가능성은
[목을 가다듬음] 많이 낮아 보이는데
>> 어, [콧방귀] 기다리는 기간이 너무
오래 걸리면 또 그 또한 뭐 기회
비용이다 보니까 그 시점으로 우리
왕부장님 생각을 좀 여쭤보고
싶었습니다. 아무튼 요런 기업들
저희가 또 반도체가 쉴 때 봐야 되는
반대편에 있는 어 기업분 중에 하나가
아닌가 생각하는데 그런 취지에서 오늘
살펴봐 주신게 아닌가 하는 생각을
갖고 넘어가 보겠습니다. [콧방귀]
미국 전일 어떻게 됐는지 창민 프로와
함께 보겠습니다.
전일시 미국 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
어젯밤 미국 정신은 메타발 홍풍
속에서 반도체와 기술주 중심으로 상승
마감했습니다.
우선 시장 전반을 살펴본 뒤에 오늘
특징 중인 메타 자세히 다뤄볼
예정입니다. 먼저 지수 보시겠습니다.
SP 500은 0.8% 오은
7,540선에서 마감했고 나스닥이
1.3% 러셀이 1.2% 올랐으며
자우는 0.3% 3% 상승에
거쳤습니다.
가장 눈에 띄는 것은 필라돌피아
반도체 지수로 하루 3% 급등하며
지수 상승을 주도했습니다. 다만
시장의 폭은 좀 좁은 모습을 보이고
있는데 예 시카총의 가중 S&P
500이 연출 이후 10% 가량
오르고 동일 가중 지수는 7%
상승해서 대형 기술주 솔림이 아직 좀
이어지고 있는 모습으로 보이고
있습니다. 다음으로 우측의 SMP
500 업종별 보시겠습니다. 어 11
섹터 11개 섹터 중 여섯 개의
섹터가 올랐는데요. 정부 기술과 자유
소비제가 1% 중반으로 가장 강한
모습 보였고요. 금융이 1%
상승했습니다. 반면 필수 소비제와
에너지가 나란히 1% 중반 하락하며
채화이었고 유틸리티도 하락했습니다.
경기 방어주에서 성장주로 좀 자금이
도는 장세였다고 정리해 드릴 수
있겠습니다. 다음으로 금리와 유가
보겠습니다. 미국체 10년물이
4.5% 55% 그 하루 기준 3
3b 가량 내렸지만 그 4.5%보다
높은 수준이라 금리보담은 좀 아직
존재하는 것으로 보이고요. WTI
기준으로 2%대 하락한 WTI는
2%대 하락한 배럴당
72달러선이고요.
이유는 미안 갈등에도 불구하고 실제
공급 차질이 제한적이라는 점이
확인돼서 좀 하락한 모습 보인 것으로
보입니다. 다음으로 그 좌측 빅테크와
주요 종목 보시면 메타가 5% 가까이
급등하며 시장 상승을 주도했습니다.
자세한 내용은 특징주에서
말씀드리겠습니다. 그리고 다음으로
브로드컴도 3%대 올랐는데 메타의
자체칩을 함께 설계하는 파트라는 점이
부된게 이슈가 돼서 상승 요인으로
적용했고요. 반면 엔비디아는 1%
가까이 빠졌습니다. 그리고
하이퍼스케일러의 자체 칩 확대가
GPU 의존도를 낮추는 방향이라서이
부분이 엔비디아의 주가 하락에 좀
영향을 준 것으로 보이고요.
그리고 테슬라가 3%대 그리고
마이크로소프트와 아마존이 1%대
상승했고요. 그리고 알파벳이 1%
정도 하락했습니다.
다음으로 반도체 쪽 보시겠습니다.
마이크론이 4% 대, AMD가 5%
대, 램리서치가 3%대 오르며 업종
전반이 좀 강한 모습 보여줬고요.
특히 샌디스크가 7% 넘게 급등했는데
그 메타와 플래시 스토리지 장기공
공급 계약을 맺었다는 소식이 좀
직접적인 재료였습니다. 그래서 공급
계약을 선점한 업체에 프리미엄이 뽑는
공면인만큼 국내 메모리 업체도 좀
우구적인 환경으로 적용할 수 있다고
생각했습니다. 다음으로 52주 신고가
종목들도 좀 짚어 보겠습니다.
유나이티드 헬스케어가 신고가를 쓰며
연초 이후 30%대 상승 이어갔고요.
네트워크 장비에는 아리스타, 보안에는
포티넥도 신고가 대열에 올랐습니다.
>> 얘 인프라 투자가 10을 넘어서
네트워킹과 보완으로 좀 번지고 있는
모습으로 보시면 되겠고요.
여기에 철도의 CSX, 물료의
익스피다이터스, 금융의 스테이트
스트리트까지 이름을 올려 신고가가
기술주 바깥으로 좀 확산되고 있는
점이 보이는 52조 신고가였습니다.
같은 맥락에서 광신주 쪽에서 루멘텀이
11% 급등한 것도 눈에 띄는데
데이터 센터 확장이 광섭리와 광무들
수요로 이어진다는 기대가 반영된
것으로 보입니다. 오늘의 특징주 메타
말씀드리겠습니다. 어제 하루에만 칩
모델 클라우드 세갈래 뉴스가
쏟아졌고요. 주가는 5% 가까이
올랐습니다. 결론부터 말씀드리면
칩으로 비용을 낮추고 모델을 저가에
팔아 접변을 넓히고 남는 인프라는
클라우드로 수익커한다는 AI 자립과
수익화의 큰 그림을 하루에
보여줬습니다.
우선 첫 번째로 자체 AI 아이리스에
대해서 말씀드리겠습니다. 로이터가
확인한 내부 메모에 따르면 메타는
9월부터 아이리스 양산에 들어가고
커뮤팅 인프라를 올해 7GW에서 내년
14GW로 두 배 확장할 계획입니다.
1기W가 약 80만 가구의 전력에
해당하는 규모라 규모를 좀 짐작해
보실 수 있을 것으로 보입니다.
그리고 브로드컴이 설계를 돕고
TSMC가 생산하는데 칩 테스트가
6주 만에 큰 결함 없이 끝났다는
사실이 이번에 처음 확인됐습니다.
그래서 5년 넘게 난항을 겪던 자체
칩개발이 궤도에 올랐다는 의미로
해석할 수 있고요. 그리고 배경은
명확한데 엔비디아와 AMD GPU
도입에 드는 시간과 비용 부담을 좀
덜고 외부 의존도를 낮추겠다는 의도로
보입니다.
메타는 송상 1년 이상인 칩 출시
주기를 6개월로 당겨서 2027년까지
신제품을 이어갈 계획이고 올해 AI
인프라 지출만 1,450억 달러에
달할 것으로 예상됩니다.
그리고 아울라 반도체 풍기와 가격
인상 대비해서 성공전자 메모리
샌디스카의 플래시 스토리지 그리고
스미토모 전기의 광섭률을 단연 장기
계약으로 선정했다는 점을
발표했습니다. 그래서 애플마저 가격
인상에 나서게 만든 메모리 구족면에서
증설 목표를 지키기 위한 조치로
보이고요. 하이퍼스켈러의 자체
치박대가 국내 메모리 수요로도 연결될
수 있다는 점으로 보입니다. 그리고
두 번째로 저가용 모델 뮤지스파크
1.21을 출시했습니다.이
모델의 성격은 저가 기반의 에이전트
특화 모델로 정리될 수 있는데요.
코딩 최상의 성능이 아니라 가격과
자동화 처리 능력으로 시장에
진입하려고 하는 전략으로 보입니다.
그래서 메타 자체 벤치마크에서도 툴
사용과 병렬 작업 처리 같은 에이전트
영역은 경쟁사 최상의 모델을 앞섰는데
그 순수 코딩 종도에서는 이들을 못
미친다고 스스로 인정하는 모습
보였고요. 대신 가격은 경쟁사의 1/
수준입니다. 라마를 무료로 풀어오던
메타가 처음으로 AI 모델의 과금을
시작했다는 점에서 좀 유료 API로의
전략 전환을 보여준 모습으로도
보입니다.
다음으로 세 번째 이슈 말씀드리면
클라우드 사업 검토입니다. 저커버그가
그 블룸버그 인터뷰에서 AI 인프라
일부를 외부에 빌려주는 방안을
살펴보고 있다고 직접적으로
밝혔습니다. 그래서 컴퓨팅을 쓰겠다는
외부 제한 금액이 워낙 높아서 경우에
따라 내부에서 쓰는 것보다 그
빌려주는 편이 합리적일 수 있다는
주장입니다.
>> 그래서 주목하셔야 점은 저카보그가이를
잉여 자원의 처분이 아니라 화방을
방어하는 안전판으로 규정해 놓는
것으로 확인하시면 되겠고요. 자체
수요가 줄더라도 AWS나 에저처럼
장기 판매가 가능한 그 수요가 좀
충분하다는 물이 보여집니다.
그리고 흥미롭다고 언급한 점이
스페이스엑셀의 방식인데 맨피스 데이터
센터를 엔트로피과 구글의 프리미엄을
받고 단기 임대하는 모델이 2030년
매출 1천억 달러 규모로 추정될만큼
실질적인 대형 시장으로 판단한 것으로
보이고요. 그래서 신규로 진출하고자
하는 좀 의지가 보이는 그런
발표였습니다.
>> 그래서 오늘 내용 정리가 있습니다.
시장은 반도체와 메타가 좀 끌어올린
리스본 하루였고 유가는 리스크
프리미엄이 좀 되돌려지는 중으로
보입니다. 그 중심에 메타 메타의 칩
모델 클라우드 세 방향의 AI
수익화에 대한 답을 내놓는 시점이
전반적인 외모리 시장의 상승을
주도했다고 보여집니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 메타가 연일 시장에 큰
화두들을 던지는데 오늘 2부에서 메타
관련한 내용을 최부 사장님 좀 더
얘기해 주십니까?
분은 아직 전받지 못했어. [웃음]
소통이 무조건 아니에요.
소통해 보겠습니다. [웃음]
아, 왜냐면 이제 저도 얘기를 쭉
들으면서 그래서 한국의 메모리
업체들은 어떻게 되나라는 질문을
머릿속에 하게 됐는데 어, [콧방귀]
큰 그림에서 긍정적인가 부정적인가
어, 긍정도 부정도 있어서 조금 더
명류한 결론을 내려 주시면 어떨까
하는 생각에서 물어봤는데
모르겠습니다. [웃음]
네. 우리 [목을 가다듬음]
문상무 최부사장 2부에서 언급을 좀
해해 주시지 않을까 기대하면서 넘어가
보겠습니다. 가상자산으로 [콧방귀]
넘어가 볼게요. 우리 준혁주의님
가상자산 어떻습니까?
>> 네. 가상자산 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
가상자 시장 우선 결론부터 말씀드리면
어 나쁘지 않은 흐름으로 계속
유지되고 있다. 이렇게 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 우선 세일러발
충격이 어 한 번씩 오고 나서부터는
어 그걸 시장이 좀 수긍하고 있는
모습으로 가고 있다 이렇게 생각이
들고요. 어 주요 시선 62,000불
정도 부근을 잘 지켜주고 있다는 좀
더 굉장히 고무적인 거 같습니다. 어
제가 아예 없다라고 했던 육가마 전쟁
그 지정확적 리스크에 대해서도 어
어느 정도 어 탄력성을 좀 보여주고
있지 않나는 생각은 개인적으로 하고
있고 그 오히려 전쟁이 실질적으로
발발했을 때 가장 먼저 충격 흡수하고
반대한 자산 사실 가장 자산이거든요.
그때 물론 소재가 있이긴 했지만 이따
페럴이 업데이트한 뷰에서도
말씀드리겠지만 어 그런 쪽에서도 어느
정도 비트코인이 어 단기 저점을 본게
아닌가 하는 생각을 하고 있는 어
분석가들이 조금 있는 거 같습니다.
그래서 어 단기 저점은 지나봐야
저희가 알 수 있지만 어쨌든 이제는
어 상승의 흐름이 아니라 조금 기간
조정이나 어 횡보의 흐름으로 들어간
조금 안정세 하향 안정세의 흐름은 어
있지 않나이 정도 생각 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 어 비트 장기
차트 보시면 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
200주 이평선 잘 지키고 있고요.
200주 이평선은 역사적으로 항상 어
저점 부근이었습니다. 어 비트코인
피앤 그레이드 인덱스 보시면 익스트림
피어 구간 각단적 공포 구간의 22
정도 기록하고 있고요. 비트코인 현물
ETF 순위 순유출 보시면 다시
유출세로 돌긴 했는데 어 그 유출세가
크진 않았습니다. 한 84일년 정도가
유출이 되면서 7월 8일 날에는
유출세가 있었다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 그 션 패럴이라고 제가
지금까지 한 세 번 정도 말씀드린 어
애널리스트가 있는데 톱리가 수장으로
있는 펀드 스트레의 어 리서치
헤드다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
선페럴이 계속해서 암호화폐 시장에
대한 뷰를 말해 주고 있는데 이번에는
긍정적이지도 부정적이도 않은 어 그런
뷰를 전달해 준 거 같아서 한번
가져와 봤습니다. 어 여기 있는
내용들 중에서 가장 중요한 것만
말씀드리면 될 거 같은데요. 어
어쨌든 가장 중요한 거는 중기적
확실이 제한적이다라고 하고
스트레티지의 자본 구조 수정이
잠재적인 비트코인의 공격 공급원이고
어 상승과 하락 위험의 균형이
팽팽하다라고 말씀을 말을 해
줬습니다. 그래서 어 지금 새로운
상승장의 시작이다라고 그 발언하긴 좀
애매하지만 어 비관론이 계속 지속돼서
어 비공이 거의 3만 불 4만 불까지
정도 빠질 수도 있다라고 한 거가 어
조금 걷어지고 전술적으로 환경이 좀
잘 세팅된 거는 같다라고 말해 주고
있고 어 미국과 이란이 지정확정적인
이슈가 좀 다시 붉어지고 있는데
2월에서 4월까지 지정확정의 리스크가
좀 올라갈 때마다 비트 가격을 좀
탄력성을 보인 부분은 있었다라고 말한
점이 긍정적이다라고 말해줬고 결국에
이제 펀트래시이 어떻게 하고 있냐
자기가 리서치해도 들어 있는 자기
전략 팀에서 어떻게 하고 있는지를
조금 공개를 해 줬는데요. 어
리스크를 조금 추가했다라고 합니다.
그니까 위험 자산을 조금 선호 그
조금 추가를 했는데 비트코인
[목을 가다듬음] 바깥쪽에서
비트코인이 아는 다른 자산들을 조금
추가해 줬다라고 어 비율를 던져
줬는데요. 비트코인보다는 이더리움이나
솔라나 같은 다른 체인들 그니까 우리
소위 말하는 알트코인 같은 것들에
조금 비중을 실어줬고 그리고
갤럭시라고 하는 상장 미국 상장
주식과 그 로비누드 로비누드 같은
주식들을 조금 담았다라고 합니다. 어
그래서 비트코인 외의 자산대로 한
이유는 비트코인이 뭔가 조금 호재성이
있는 어 이슈가 조금 덜하다라고 보고
있고 아무래도 위험 자산 시장이
선호가 조금 더 더해지다 보면 어
이더리움이나 솔로나 같은 알트코인
시장으로 조금 더 운풍이 될 수
있다라고 어 비뷰를 실어줬습니다.
사실 오히려 이거는 시장을 더 강하게
보고 있는게 아닌가 하는 생각 할 수
있을 것 같고요. 갤럭시나 후드 같은
데이터 센터 관련되는 기업들 그리고
예측이나 어 암호화폐 거래 쪽으로 어
많이 비중이 실려 있는 후드 같은
기업들도 로비후드 같은 기업들도
굉장히 좋을 수가 있을 것 같다.
그래서 한번 좀 추가해 봤다라고
언급을 해 준 상황입니다. 그래서
상승은 아니지만 상승과 하락이 지금
굉장히 밸런스가 좀 잘 맞춰져 있는
상황이고 하락에 대한 모멘텀이 어느
정도 좀 걷어진 거 같고 어 저희
표현으로 프라이스 선반형이 조금 된
거 같다라는 식의 뷰를 던져줬다
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다. 어
가장 왼쪽 밑에 내려와서 보시면 제가
제목을 비트코인 이더리움이 전부가
아니다라고 써 놨는데요. 어, 방금이
천패럴의 뷰에 따 뷰와 같이 약간
괴를 같이 한다라고 볼 수 있을 것
같은데 예를 들어서 위험 자산 시장
선호가 올라온다라고 하면 어, 그
주변에 있는 섹터들 저희가 뭐
소부장이 굉장히 강하게 올라오는 그
베타가 높은 그런 모습을 보여주듯이
어, 다른 시장들 뭐 예측 시장이나
아니면 뭐 그 실물 그 토크나 주식
같은 것들 시장이 강하게 급성장할 수
있다라는 뷰를 계속해서 던질 수가
있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 여기 왼쪽
밑에 있는 차트를 보시면 이게 월별
그 거래량이 거래량이다라 보시면 될
거 같은데요. 어 지금이 예측 시장의
거래량이 급상승하고 있는 모습을 보실
수가 있을 것 같습니다. 물론 현재
지금 가장 그 가장 오른쪽에서 바로
왼쪽에 있는 가장 오른쪽에서 두 번째
있는 어 그 차트는 6월 달에 어
지금 월드컵이 활발하게 열리고 있기
때문에 어 월드컵에 대한 부분을
반영한 거라고 참고해 주시면 될 거
같지만 어쨌든 24년에 지금 정치적
그 트럼프 대통령이 당선될 때 어
대통령 선거 때문에 갑자기 성장을
했지만 지금 그때부터 10열배 이상
성장했습니다. 열배 이상 그 거래량에
성장했기 때문에 이것이 향후에 어떻게
더 성장할지는 저희가 계속 추적을 해
보면 될 거 같고 어 사실상 이게
파이가 커지면 커질수록이 거래량은
더욱 더 올라올 수밖에 없고 거기서
나오는 어 거래 수수료 같은 것들로
어 환산하게 된다라고 하면 예측 시장
쪽에서도 어 매출이 굉장히 잘 나오는
그런 비즈니스가 앞으로 형성이 될 수
있지 않을까 하는 말씀을 드릴 수
있을 것 같고요. 어 폴리마켓과
칼시가 가장 양대 산맥인데요.
폴리마켓을 항상 말씀을 많이
드렸었는데 폴리마켓의 어 거리량은
굉장히 높은 편이긴 하지만 칼씨가 좀
더 높습니다.이 이유는 명확한데
칼씨는 어 CFTC에 등록이 돼 있는
어 정부 규제를 받는 예측
시장이고요. 폴리마켓은 거의 뭐 어
국외에 있는 사람들이 그냥 뭐
VPN을 타고 들어와야 될 정도로
아직 승인을 받지는 못한 어 그런
예측 시장에다라 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 그래서 나중에 탄력성이
조금 더 높은 거는 칼실 확률이 조금
높다. 그냥 어 칼씨는 그 어제
스테이블 코인 말씀드렸지만 USDC
서클이하고 있는 규제에 조금 들어와
있는 예측 시장이다.이 정도 봐
주시면 될 거 같고 폴리마켓은 어
이제 USDT 말씀드렸지만 아직
안전하지만 아직 안전하게 그 규제
위에 올라와 있지 않지만 사람들이
많이 쓰는 어이 정도 예측 시장이다
이렇게 봐 주시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 벌써 6월 마지막 주후
기준으로 봤을 때 거래량이 두 배
이상 차이 나거든요. 어 폴리마켓은
한 2년 정도가 되고 칼치는 한
5빌년 정도가 되니까 규모 자체는
크게 차이가 많이 납니다. 어쨌든
지금 24년부터 비교를 해 봤을 때
어 지금 그 예측 시장에서의 거래량이
굉장히 많이 올라오고 있고 10배
이상 성장한 현재 모습을 보여주고
있고요. 어 그런 부분들이 꾸준하게
우상향하고 있다는 점은 지금 비트코인
시장이 안 좋게 지금 거래가 되고
있는 우아향하고 있는 추세임에도
불구하고 예측 시장이나 뭐 토큰 주식
시장 같은 경우에도 성장을 잘 일뤄내
주고 있다. 그리고 오히려 이런
하락장에 이런 뉴스들이 굉장히 많이
나오고 있는 거는 좀 긍정적이고
건강하다라고 말씀을 드릴 수가 있을
것 같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 두 가지가 좀
궁금한데요. 우선 왼쪽 아래 표를
보면 예측 시장 전체적인 어 어떤
볼륨이이 막대 그래프의 키이고
>> 그 구성들을 이렇게 색깔로 표시해
주셨어요.
>> 어 폴리마켓 같은 경우에는 미국과
미국과
미국 외인가요? 지팅하는데
>> 구분을 좀 해 주셔서
>> 칼씨가 미국 그냥 미국이다라고 보면
될 거 같고요. 칼씨가이 초록색
연두색 쪽이 칼인데요. 폴리마켓은
미국의 베이스를 두고 있기는 하지만
어 미국 외에 있는 국가들에인
사람들도 VPN통 VPN 등을 통해서
만 참여합니다. 이게 칼 폴리마켓이
미국 베이스다라고 말씀드린 이유는
미국에서 비즈니스 하고 있지만 주정부
차원에서 어 이거 도박이다라고 치부가
돼서 어 막히 막히거나 지금 소송에
들어가서 지금 영업을 중지되고 있는
그런 주들이 몇 군데 있습니다.
그러면 그런 주에 이제 GPS가
잡히게 된다라고 하면 거기서 셧다운이
되는 거거든요. 그렇기 때문에 이제
VPN을 켜야 되는 건데 둘 다
미국을 베이스로 두고 있지만 어쨌든
칼씨는 규제 위에 올라와서 뭐 그냥
접근할 때 그냥 접근할 수 있지만
폴리마켓은 그렇지 않다. 렇치 않은
지역들도 있다. 이렇게 보시면
됩니다.
>> 네. 1년 전으로 되돌아가 보면
칼시하고 그냥 전 세계를 대상으로
하는 폴리마켓 두 개밖에 없다가
오피니언이라는 곳이 어 상당히 좀
치고 나왔다가 거의 없어졌고 어
그밖의 것들은 존재가 좀 없는 거
같다는 생각을 보면서 들었습니다. 저
하나만 더 여쭤보고 넘어갈게요. 여기
왼쪽 아래편 제목이
>> 어 비트코인 이더리움이 전부가
아니다라고 되어 있는데
>> 어이 제목을 제가 이해를 못 했어요.
어, 비트코인 이더리움이 어쨌든 이제
가장 자산을 거래하는 데에서 가장
대표되는 두 가지 코인이라고 생각이
드는데
>> 어, 그 외의 시장을 좀 봤으면
좋겠다라고 말씀을 드리는 부분이
있습니다. 결국
>> 아, 지금 가상자산 말고 예측
시장이란 얘긴가요? 예측 시장, 토큰
실물 자산 시장, 스테이블콘이 세
개를 가장 세 개로 말씀을 드릴 수
있을 것 같은데 그쪽에서는 이제 뭐
그 자산의 가격이 오르다기보다는 그
마켓의 그 크기 자체가 굉장히
급성장하고 있다는 점 좀 말씀을
드리고 싶었는데 그게 좀 오해가 있을
수 있을 것 같고요. 어쨌든 가장
자산 시장을 그냥 거래하는 거로 봤을
때는 비트코인 이더리움이 대표적으로
될 수 있을 것 같고 그 이외에도
많은 성장을 지금 비트코인이나
이더리움이 약세장으로 가고 있는
와중에 어 가장 큰 성장을 보이고
있는게 예측 시장 어 그리고 실물
자산 시장 이런 것들이 조금 될 수
있을 것 같다. 이렇게 그 말씀드릴
수 있는데 그 중에 하나가 예측
시장이다 이렇게 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다.
>> 네. 그 비트코인 이더리움과 아래
표가 관련이 있는 건 아니고 네네.
관네 어쨌든 예측 시장이 성장을
굉장히 많이 이루고 있다. 이런 걸
조금 설명드리고자 말씀드렸습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 투자자들이 전통 자산이
아닌 가상자산 예측 시장 자
[콧방귀] 예측 시장이라고 해야 될까
예 그런 쪽에도 관심을 계속 갖고
여기에도 또 이제 어떤 시장과
비즈니스 모델이 계속 형성이 되고
있으니까요. 어, 예측 시장에서 두
각을 받는 기업들을 저희가 직접
투자할 수 있는 날이 있다면 또 높은
멀티플을 받을 수도 있겠다.
>> 이거를 약간 비상장이나 VC 레벨에서
지금 투자가 이미 이루어지고 있는데
트럼프 대통령이나 케빈 워시 같은 어
고의 공무원들이 이미 투자가돼
있더라고요.
>> 아, 본인.
>> 네.
아예 관조인가
돼 있는 트럼프 자세히 살펴보진
않았지만 관련된 VC들을 통해서 이미
투자가 돼 있는 걸로 제가 알고
있습니다. 알겠습니다. 그럼 점점 더
제도권으로 들어올 확률이 높아지지
않을까는 생각도 드네요.
>> 1부 여기서 마치도록 하겠습니다. 어
함께 해 주신 채무탄 여러분
감사드리고요. 잠시 후 2부에서
뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
>> [음악]
[음악]
>> เฮ
เฮ
[음악]
>> [음악]
>> 안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 예정을
체슬리 투자자분과 함께 체슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 7월 10일 즐거운
금요일 2분서 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
자 어제 미국 시장도 어 기분 좋게
반등을 했습니다.
자 내용 한번 쭉 한번 볼까요? 예.
필반지수 상승률이 3.1%로
요지수 중에 가장 높았고요.
그렇지만 아직 좀 갈게 많습니다. 좀
남아 있습니다. 고점 대비 한 11%
정도 하락한 상황이고요.음
16%까지 갔다가 어 최근한
어 하락폭을
회복하는 어 그런 상황입니다.
종목별로 보면은 그런데 아직 뭐 두
자릿수 하락한 것들이 많아 가지고
TSM 정도가 이제 뭐 크게 많이
오르지 않았기 때문에 최근에 빠질 때
덜 빠졌고요. -8.5%
마이콘이 한 18.3%가 아직 하락해
있고 ASML이 -9.3% 3%
그리고 대표 장비주인 어플라이드
머티리얼이나 램리서치 18%씩 나란이
빠져 있습니다. 그리고 나머지
종목들도 대체로 10에서 한 20%
정도씩 하락해 있기 때문에 어 좀
회복하려면
시간이 필요한 거 같고요.
어제 마이크론의 미국 투자 확대
발표가 있는데 있었는데
2035년까지
총 200빌리언 달러를 투자하기로
했는데 이거를 250빌리언 달러로
상향 조정했다는
발표가 있었습니다.
이유는 AI [콧방귀] 시대의 메모리
수요 급증이 배경이 있고요. 어 장기
목표로는 디램의 40%를 미용 내에서
생산한다는 것이고요.
그래서 최근에 이제 투자 발표가 많이
일어남에 따라서
반도체 어 종합 반도체 기업들의
케펙스를 좀 봤는데요. 삼성하고
SK하닉스 어 마이크론 이런 메모리
기업하고 TSMC 인텐
기업들의 케펙스를 보면은 어 증가도
증가하지만 이전보다 어 상형 조정되는
부분들이 있는 거 같습니다.
숫자들을 보면은
5계사 연간 합산이 [목을 가다듬음]
어 26년에 아 178빌리언 달러
그리고 27년에 225빌리언 달러
그리고 20 [웃음] 28년에 어
257빌리언 달러로 계속 늘어나는
상황이고
삼성 같은 경우는
올해 50빌리언 내년 61 빌려
그리고 70 그다음에 71 빌리언
대략적으로 어 내년 내후년에 11년씩
늘어나는 상황이고 SK 하이닉스 같은
경우는 올해 29빌년 내년 37
44에서 한 7 7빌년씩 이렇게
늘어나는 상황이고 마이크론이 어
[목을 가다듬음] 조금
공격적인데요. 올해 28빌년에서
내년에 45빌년으로 어 늘어난
상황이고요. 그리고 TSMC도 어
앞자리가 바뀔 정도로 늘어나고 인텔은
뭐 그냥 뭐 크게 어 변화가 없는
그런 상황인데 메모리하고 어
파운드리스가
크게 늘어나면서
전체 어
그
규모 자체도 어 계속 증가하고 있다고
보시면 될 것 같습니다. 그래서
관련주들의 이제 수혜를 계속 어
체크를 하고 있는데 반토치 장비주들
어 최근에 한 20% 내외씩 어
조정을 받았지만 연초 이후에 한
80에서 한 100% 좀 적게는
ASML 같은 경우는 한 68% 정도
어 이렇게 올라 있는 상황이고
밸루에이션을 보면은 뭐 그렇게 어
만만치 않은데 이전에 한 50배
60배 받았던 밸루에이션이 최근에
조금 착해졌습니다. 착해졌다고
하더라도 30배 후반에서 한 40배
초반 정도에 어 거래되고 있는데
숫자만 보면은 어 어플라이드
머티리얼이 38배 그리고 램
레리서치가 43배를 받고 있고요.
ASML이 42배 그리고 KL가
44.4배 그리고 테러다인이
41.5배로 배로 대체로
EPS의 방향성은 어 우상향하는
가운데 밸루에이션도 높 높고 어
주가도 높았던 상황에서 어 최근
반도체 섹터 전체에
어 낙폭이 커지면서 같이 조정받은
상황이라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
펀더멘탈은 뭐 크게
영향이 없었는데 결국 밸루에이션
과열, 가격 이런 이런 과열을 시키는
과정이 어 발생했다고 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 그 이번에 장비 투자는 아
최근 S, SK 증권에서 좀 분석을
내놨었는데 이전에 비해서 어 길고
점점 강해지는 것이 특징이기 때문에
메모리처럼 화끈하진 않다고 하더라도
사이클이 조금 오래 갈 수 있는
그리고 주가 상승이 어 꾸준히 지속될
수 있는 그런 환경을 갖췄다는 것이
대체적인 컨센서스입니다. 입니다.
어 메타 관련해서 최근에 조금 자세히
보고 있는데 아까 창프로도 잠깐
말씀해 주셨고
붙치는 부분도 있어서 보면은 어 AI
클라우드 사업 검토에 대해서 타당성이
있다라고 얘기를 했고 전체적인 맥락을
보면은 아 본격적으로 뭘 하겠다는
것은 아니라 지금 검토 단계인 거로
보고 있고
어 결국 그 시장에서 오해했던
부분이 어 컴퓨팅 파워가 남아 돌기
때문에 클라우드 사업까지 하는 거
아니냐라는 아 그런 그 좀 오해가
있었는데 저크버그가 블룸버그와의
인터뷰에서 아 클라우드 사업 가능성은
있는데 어 컴퓨팅 파워가 남아돈다는
의미는 아니다라고 단정적으로 얘기를
했습니다.
그리고 이전에 이제 저희가 얘기했었던
어 스페이스 X가
엔트로픽하고 구글에 임대 계약하는
것이 좀 흥미로워서 그 부분을 약간
벤치마킹한다는 느낌이 있고요. 그와는
별개로 어제 메타가 새로운 AI 모델
뮤즈스파크 1.2을 론칭을 했는데
이전에 버전이 아 뮤즈
스파크였습니다. 이번에 업그레이드 된
버전이 1.1이었는데 일이었는데 어
이번에는 개발자들에게 유료로 제공하는
서비스를 론칭한 것인데 아 메타는
자사의 AI 인프라에서 모델을
운영하고 어 개발자들이 모델을
접근하면서 사용하는 데이터에 따라
과금하는 형태고 가격은 다른 최상의
모델들이 제시하는 비용의 약 25%
수준으로 어 낮췄다고 합니다.데 다른
모델들이 아 제미나이 3.1% 1%
그리고 오퍼스 4.8 그리고 GPT
5.5라서
어
중상급의
어 모델이라고 어 보시면 될 거
같고요. 어 배치마킹 테스트에서
숫자들을 보면은 어 대체로
오퍼스
수준 정도라고
어 보시면 될 것 같습니다. 그래서
오퍼 수준이 엔트로픽에서 가장 높은
상 최상의 버전은 아니고 그 밑에
있는 버전인데 어 수준의 어 벤치마킹
테스트에서 비슷한 결과를 얻었고
가격은 25% 수준이니까 가성비
측면에서 어 괜찮은 서비스라고 어
보여줄 수 있을 것 같습니다.
개발자들이 일정 토큰 한도까지 무료로
사용할 수 있고 해당 한도를 넘으면
어 비용을 지불하는 형태라고 보시면
될 거 같고요. 그래서 메타가 약간
좀 변화하는 모습들이
조금씩 조금씩 아 새로운 서비스도
내놓고 또는 클라우드 사업에 대한
검토도 하고 있고 그런 부분들이 좀
시장에서
그 좀 약간은 좀 긍정적으로 평가하는
모습들인 거 같고요. 최근에 주가도
한 며칠간 좀 한 10여% 정도
상승한 그런 상태입니다.
지금 밸류에이션 같은 경우는
15.3배 3배 거래되고 있어서
지난번에 많이 떨어졌을 때는 한
13배 초반까지 떨어졌었는데
메타에서 보기 어려운 어
밸루에이션까지 어 떨어졌다가 그냥
최근에 15배 정도까지 회복한
상황입니다.
미국 기업들은
뭐 약간 이슈가 생겼을 때 어 바로
자진에서 나와 가지고 이렇게
인터뷰하는 모습들이 좀 괜찮은 거
같고요.
그 어닝콜은 7월 29일 날 실적
발표와 같이
있을 텐데 어느 정도 시장에 좀
오해는 부분들 이런 부분들이 어
해소되어 가는 과정인 거 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 네. 감사합니다.
EPS는 뭐 다 미국의 테크이나
전부다 다 EPS는 다 우상향
>> 예,
>> 지금 잘 하고 있다. 그죠?
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 말씀하신 대로 이제 PR 너무 약간
높았다 싶으면 또 최근에 주가
조정으로 인해서 상당히 매력적인
수준. 야, 메타금
>> 15배까지 지금 15패 밑에서
거래됐으네. 예, 그렇습니다.
그래서 어, 장비주의 뭐 밸루에이션
보면 뭐 그 역사적으로 이런
밸루에이션을 받았을까 싶을 정도로
>> 40배, 50배 막 이렇게 어,
갔었던 거는
>> 어, 조금 과하다 싶긴 했는데
>> 어, 그런 과한 구간에서 10%씩
주가 조정이 나온 거 같습니다.
우리나라 장비주는 주가 조정이 뭐
30%
고점 대비 지금 30% 40% 이렇게
빠진 주식들이 꽤 많더라고 보니까
>> 네
>> 그것도 6월 달에 신고가 났는데
>> 그렇죠 6월 달에 신고가 났는데 5점
제비 막 40% 빠져
지금 삼성전자 하이닉스만 그런게
아니라이
>> 두 배짜리 레그리지 때문에 전자
하이닉스의 예. 변동성이 너무 커진
거 아닌가 요런 얘기들이 많긴 한데
뭐 기타 두 배짜리 레버리지 없는
주식들도 변동성 엄청 심해요. 지금
이쪽이 안이 오르기도 했습니다. 어
>> 20% 빠졌어도 100% 넘는
주식들이 많으니까요. 여전히
차시전 욕구를
느낄 만한 소재가 나타나면 어 바로
이제 어 차익 실현이 나서거나 아니면
경계 매물이 나오거나 하는 거
같습니다.
>> 음. [목을 가다듬음]
>> 자판 미국 시장에서 10년물 국제
금리가 어 다행히 좀 소폭 빠져
가지고 4.5로 끝나고 유가도
71.9이 구이 유가가 취소을 때는
아이가 또 80 90가면 어떡하나 뭐
이런 두려움 때문에 그러면서 이제
신앙이 공포을 갖고 빠지는데
유가도 다시 빠지는 모습이 나왔고
10년물 국적 금매도 빠지는 모습이
나오면서 시장에 약간은 안도랠리가
좀 이어진 거 같습니다.
12주 신고가 중식을 쭉 보니까
유나이티 헬스 그룹이 12조 신고가
나왔고
>> 그다음에는
보니까
어 아까 네트워크 뭐 보안
>> 예 그렇죠 보는 쪽이
>> 예 또
>> 신고가를
>> 포티넥넷 같은 경우에
>> 어 포티넷 그런 세 번째
>> 아리스타 네트워크
>> 예
>> 요런 기업들도 눈에 보이
>> 약간 좀 다변화되는 그런 모습들이
나타나고 있는 거 같습니다
예
>> 저 밑에 스테이 스트리트이 보험
회사죠이 아 보험회사인가펀드
>> 예 운용사 예
>> 그럼 ETF 운용사가 심족 신고가를
내고 있다는 말은 장이 그렇게 뭐
앞으로 조심해야 될 장은 아닌
거예요. 그죠? 같습니다.
됐습니다. 자, 그러면 미국 시장
여기까지 하고 국내 시장으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.
네. 코스피 지수 전일 0.6% 6%
상승으로 마감을 했고요. 코스닥
1.1%
상승 마감했습니다. 어 코스닥이
코스피 대비 상대적으로 좀
강했었고요. 수급적으로 봐 주시면
개인 추하자가 1조 3,억
매도했습니다. 반면에 외국인이
1,400억, 기관에서 1조 2,억
가량 매수세가 유입됐고요. 외인들이
선물은 계속해서 좀 매수하는
모습인데요. 7,400억 가량
매수세가 유입이 됐습니다. 어제
특징적이었던 건 개인 추사자들의
매도가이 이거 연속 나오고 있는데 전
일장에서 1조 넘게 매도했다는 점이
좀 특이했던 거 같고요.
아래 투자자별 매매 동향으로 내려가서
보면 외국인 투자자는 어제 삼성전자
2,400억 가량 매수를 했습니다.
그 외에는 삼성전기 SK 스퀘어 LG
이노텍 어 삼성 SDI SK 텔레콤
포스콜링스 등을 매수를 했고요.
매도에는 SK하이닉스, KB금융,
LG 전자, 하나오션, APR,
심텍, LI, DNA 등을
매도했습니다.
어, 기간 매수에는 SK하이닉스를 약
9,000가량 매수를 했고요. 그
외에는 삼성전자, KB 금융, 심텍,
주석 엔지니어링, 한미 반반도체 등을
매수했습니다. 기간 매도에는
삼성전기, SK 스퀘어, 이노텍,
한화 에어로, 삼성 중공업 등을
매도를 했습니다. 52주 신고가
종목은 뭐 최근 몇 거일 연속네
종목만 딱 이렇게 나오고 있는데
종목은 좀 변했다 해도 뭐 종목 수
자체가 늘어나고 있지 않습니다.
코스피에서 금모 건설 그리고
코스닥에선 데이터 솔루션, C랩 등이
신고가의 이름을 올렸습니다.
네.
자, 주요 기업들 동량 한번 쭉
보겠습니다.
>> 네. 반도체 섹터 먼저 봐 주시면
대형 반도체 주가가 나쁘지는
않았습니다. 전자가 한 0.2% 2%
상승으로 마감을 했었고요. SK닉스가
5.3%
어 상승 마감했습니다. 시간으로는
전자도 그렇고 하이닉스도 그렇고
추가적으로 좀 상승하는 모습이
나왔었고요. 아래 소부장 조목들 봐
주시면 한미 반도체 8% 그리고 주성
엔지니어링 11.5
심택이 12.7 7 이수페타가 10%
>> 급등하면서 소보장 종목들도 상당히
좋은 흐름이 나타났었던 거 같고요.
그래서 원머스 기준으로는 지금 대체로
다 좀 진한 파란색들이 많이 보이긴
하는데 그 와중에 좀 셌던 건 파크
시스템즈 그리고 심택이 좀 특징적으로
덜 빠지고 좀 올랐던 종목들이었던 거
같습니다.
아래 IT 섹터 봐 주시면 삼성
전기가 1%대 상승으로 마감을
했고요.
장 중에 한 3%까지도 밀렸었던 걸로
봤는데 그래도 오후장 들어서 좀
반등에 성공을 했습니다. LG 전자가
9% 하락 마감했고요. LG 이노텍
그리고 LG 디스플레이 등도 약세
흐름을 보였습니다. 플랫폼 섹터 전일
시장에서 좀 부진한 흐름이었고요.
네이버 카카오 다 약세였습니다. 어
니케이 지수 1.4% 4% 가량 상승
마감했는데
일본 증시도 비슷했습니다. 소부장이나
IT 정보 되게 좋았는데요. 도쿄
일렉트론이 5.5%, 무라타가 5%,
호야, 디스코, 이비덴 등도 어
상승세를 보이면서 글로벌 증시와
동조화 되는 흐름 나타났던 거
같고요. 자동차 섹터는 현대차가
3.7 하락했고 기아가 7.6
하락하면서 자동차의 하락이 멈추지
않고 계속해서 나오고 있는데 현대차피
P 10열배 밑으로 떨어진 건 로봇
모멘텀 들어오고 나서는 좀 오랜만에
보는 숫자인 거 같습니다. 소비제
섹터 봐 주시면 LG 생활 건강
아암무래퍼시픽
56% 대의 약세 흐름을 보이면서
최근 상승 좀 많이 하고 있었는데
어젯장 좀 되돌리는 현상이 나타났던
거 같습니다. 그래서 좀 반도체가 쉴
때 어떤 섹터를 볼까 해서 이제
화장품도 보고 뭐 다른 섹터도 보는데
예를 들어 이걸 반도체를 팔고
샀다라고 가정을 해도 이게 추세적으로
다른 업종이나 섹터가 올라가는게 거의
없더라고요. 그래서 좀 수남매 도나
싶어서 따라가면 또 거기도 다음날에
툭 빠져 버리고 이런 현상이 어 좀
많이 나타나고 있는데 그래서 그래서
좀 더 시장이 어려운 거 같습니다.
현재 상황이 어 피부 미용 기기로
보면 어 클래시스 5% 정도 상승
마감하면서 PO 비용 기기 섹터
내에서 어 전장에선 가장 강했던
모습이었고요.
아래 음식률 섹터로 내려가서 보면
농심 3% 3형식품도 한 3.7
하락했습니다.
월요일장인가
화요일장에 11%인가 급등하고 그
이후로 이거래일 연속도 내려오면서 그
상승분을 답도 반납을 해 버렸습니다.
그리고 백화존체인 어 어제 신세계가
한 3% 빠지는 모습이 나타났고요.
조선 철감및 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
조선주들의 하락도 멈추지 않고
있습니다. 현대 중검 하나 오션 하나
엔진 등의 약세 이름을 모였고요.
하나 오션은 22% 빠지고 전장에도
빠지고 약간 [콧방귀] 어 하락세가
좀 멈춰 좋을 거 같은데 여전히 좀
약세 흐름은 유지가 되고 있습니다.
철광이나 화학 섹터 대체로
부진했고요. 아래 방산주들 보면 하나
에어로가 8%
급락세를 또 보이기도 했었고 LIG가
2.8 현대 로템이 5%
하락했습니다. 그래서 방산주도 좀
반등 하나 싶으면 또 빠지고 반등
하나 싶으면 또 빠지고 하는 모습이
최근에 계속 연출이 되고 있고 어제
특별한 이슈 없이이 섹터도 약세름을
보였습니다.
어 바이오 섹터 봐 주시면 삼성
바이오 그리고 삼성 에피스 코스피
바이오 대체로 부진했고요. 코스닥도
시장 자체는 나쁘진 않았는데 어
바이오섹터가 좋은 흐름은
아니었습니다.
어,
그리고 바이오섹터에서 코스닥 종목
지금 HLB랑 그리고 어, [콧방귀]
페트론의 주가가
어, 오늘 프리장에서 좀 많이
빠지는데요. NXT장에서 HLB가
지금 한가를 갔고요.
>> 그리고 패트론이 22% 거래량이
터지면서 지금 NXT에서
빠지고 있는데 각각 이슈가
있더라고요. 이제 펩트론은 어제
대표님이 신한 바이오럼인가 나가셔서
지금 ồ트론이랑 릴리랑 그 마운자로
지금 한 달에 한번 아 일주일에 한
번 맞는데 그 한 달에 한 맞는
기술을 페트론과 같이 기술 개발하고
있다라고 투자자들이 알고 있었는데
대표님이 그 포럼에 나와서 어
[콧방귀] 우리가 하고 있는게
마운자로가 아니다 이런 식으로 말씀을
하신 거 같아요. 그래서 방금 전에
이제 해명 기사 같은게 나오긴 했는데
아직 제가 읽어 보진 않았거든요.
그래서 방금 나왔는데
그런 부분이 지금 주가에 좀 영향을
미치고 있고 또 HLB 간남 신약 쪽
하고 있잖아요. 근데 미국 FDA
통과를 또 실패를 하면서 이게 전에도
한번 실패했던 걸로 알고 있거든요.
그래서
>> 기대감이 좀 있었던 종목들인데 그런
부분이 지금 어 좀 안 좋은 이슈들이
나오면서 프리장에서 많이 하락하고
있다. 바이오섹터 전반에 좀 악영향을
끼칠 가능성이 있어 보입니다.
그리고 은행주 KB 금융이 0.2%
2% 오르면서 금융주들의 주가가
굉장히 탄탄한 흐름이고요.
증권주는 최근에 좀 올라오고 있었는데
어 전일장에는 키움 증권이 5.8%
약세로 마감했습니다. 엔터 쪽도 한
일주일 정도 오음새 보이다가 어
하이브 SMYC 한 2 거래 연속 좀
빠지는 흐름이 나타나고 있고요.
변합기 쪽이 그래도 전일장에 조금씩
반등에 성공을 했습니다. 현대 1렉
효성 ls1 대체로 상승세였습니다.음
자, [기침]
[목을 가다듬음]
리프트를 가져왔는데 오랜만에 이연한테
명원의 이거 그거전 반도체의 고점을
잡아내는 탑다운 방법 어 반도체의
고점을 잡아내는 방법이 있다는
말이나요?
>> 네. 뭐 딱 이걸로 잡아낸다기보다 좀
더 어 어떤 뭐 이익률도 얘기하고
이익 증가율도 저희가 얘기를 하고
하는데 둘 중에 어느게 좀 더 맞냐에
대한 이야기인 거 같습니다.
>> 그래서 저희도 뭐 이런 얘기 좀 자주
나눴었긴 한데요.
>> 어 반도체의 고점을 잡아내는 탑다운
방법이라는 제목이고요. 7월 상순이
지나면서 이제는 주가 조정을 비중
확대 기회로 볼 수 있는지 검토할
시점이다라고 하는데요. 첫 번째 이익
성장률 둔화에 대한 오해가 있다라고
하는데 최근 한국 증시 조정을 이끈
핵심은 반도체 익증가 우려라고 볼
수가 있겠고요. 반도체 가격 상승률
준화도 같은 맥락으로 볼 수가
있겠는데 어 논리는 좀 단순하다라고
합니다. 이익 증가율이 꺾이면 주가도
약세를 보일 수밖에 없다라는
것인데요. 실제로 한국 반도체 협정의
이익 증가율 2분기를 정점으로 어
둔화될 것으로 예상이 되고 하지만
이익 증가율은 주의에서 봐야 하는
데이터라고 하는데요. 특히 지금처럼
이익 증가율이 급증한 시기에는 더욱
그렇다라고 하는데 이익이 빠르게
급증한 뒤에는 기지 효과가 생기
마련이고이 경우 증가율 존화를 곧바로
위험 신호로 보기는 어렵다. 어 예를
들어 지금처럼 영업 이익이 이미
1000% 증가했다면 다음 분계는
100 1500%씩 더 높은 증가율을
기록해야지만 이익 증가율 상승이
이어진다라고 볼 수 있고요. 하지만
현실적으로 이런 흐름이 계속되기는 좀
어렵다. 어, 두 번째는 반도 체익이
200% 이상 증가했던 사례를 뽑아
주셨는데요. 과거 SK하이닉스 사례를
보면 SK이닉스의 EPS 증가율이
200% 이상 급증했던 시기는 두 번
있었다라고 하고 2013년과
17년인데 첫 번째는 증가율은
꺾었지만 반도체 왕이 이어지면서
EPS 자체는 계속 증가했기
때문이라고 하고요. 당시 SK하이닉스
주가 고점은 그보다 약 10개월 뒤인
20 2014년 7월 달에
나왔었다라고 합니다. 어 두 번째는
2017년이라고 하고요. 이때도
반도체 슈퍼사이클이 진행 중이었었고
EPS는 2016년 8월부터 반등하기
시작을 했는데 어 2017년 8월에는
EPS 증가율이 고점을 찍었었다라고
합니다. 그래서 어 좀 신점이
다르다라고 하고요. 하지만 실제 주가
고점은 그보다 약 9개월 뒤
2018년 5월에 나타났었다라고 해서
아까 첫 번째로 꼽아준 이익 성장률
두나 자체가 주가 고점 시그널로
해석은 하지 않아야 된다는
이야기고요. 어 세 번째 중요한 것은
이익 증가율이 아니라 오히려 이익률로
볼 수가 있겠는데요. 이번에도 구조는
같지 않을까라는 의견인데 작년 7월
EPS가 바닥을 찍었다면 올해
7월에는 EPS 증가율이 고점을 찍는
것이 자연스러운 흐름이다. 기조 효과
때문이라고 볼 수가 있겠고요.
그렇다면 앞으로 EPS가 계속
늘어나더라도 증가율이 800%를 넘지
못하면 어 주가는 하락해야 할까
고민을 해 보면 그럴 가능성 좀
납다라고 하고요. 시장 보는 핵심은
증가율 자체가 아니라 이익의 절대
수준과 이익률의 지속성 때문이라고
하고 그렇다면 반도체 주가 정점을
가장 잘 설명하는 지표는 무엇일까
고민해 보면 어 지난 12여년간 어
반도체 사이클을 볼 때 활용했던 선행
지표는 대여섯 개 정도가 있었다라고
하고요. 그중 이익과 관련해 주가를
가장 잘 설명했던 지표는
이익률이었다. 현재 애널리스트 추정
기준으로는 올해 4분기가 이익률의
정점이라고 볼 수가 있고요. 다만
이익률 추정치는 매우 자주 바뀐다라고
하고 따라서 지금 특정 분기를
고점으로 단정할 필요는 없다라고
합니다. 어 더 중요한 것은 앞으로
이익률 전망이 어떻게 변하는지를
판단하는 거라고 하고요. 결론은
분명한데 지금처럼 이익 급 증하는
국면에서는 기조 효과를 지해하긴
하지만 이익 증가율보다는 더 믿을
만한 집별의 이익률이다.라는
이야기를 했습니다.
아래 표를 봐 주시면 2013년
9월에 APS 증가율이 고점을
찍었었는데요. 실제로 주가 고점은
언제 나왔냐라고 보면 2014년 6월
저렇게 빨간색 글시로 해 놓으셨는데
EPS 증가율은 이제 고점을 짓고
내려오는 구간에도 주가는 그 기간
동안 상승을 했었다라는 걸 저희가 알
수 있고요.
어 그리고 오른쪽으로 보면이
SK닉스의 EPS 증글 현재입니다.
그래서 지금 뭐 800%대 EPS
증가율이 나타나고 있는데이 부분이
2분기 고점 찍고 좀 넘어가면 살짝
내려오는 걸로 지금 보이죠. 약간.
그래서 이익의 정점 이익 증가율의
정점은 이번 상반기 때 끝이 났다.
4반기 되면이 기울기 자체 내려오는
구간이 된다라고 현재 추정치상 되어
있는 상황입니다.
제가 과거 그럼 어떻게 그 실제
이익률과 SK하이닉스가 움직였었냐를
가져왔는데요. 블룸버그 자료인데
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 2012년부터 나옵니다. 근데 이게
조금씩 근데
무조건 이익률만 보고 판단하기는 좀
어렵다라는 생각도 좀 들었는데요.
2014년도에
어 OPM이 이제 제가 표시를 해
놨습니다. 노란색으로 빨간색으로
동그라미 쳐 놨는데 OPM이 고점을
딱 찍고 어 그럼 저때 팔았었냐라고
하면 오히려 주가 좀 더 올라갔었던
기억이 있고요. 이거를 저도 어제
고민하다가 문상문님한테도 좀
여쭤봤는데
[콧방귀]
저때 83%를 찍었지만 이미
시장에서는
어느 정도 그 내년이나 그 다다음
분기에
이익률이 꺾일 거라고 예상을 해서
파는 투자자들이 있었다. 그래서 두
개 분기 정도 선행해서 반도체 주가가
미리 빠지잖아요, 항상. 그래서 그런
부분이 이걸 보면은 느낄 수가 있었고
2018년이 좀 더 명확하게 저희가
알 수 있는데요. 이때 SK하이닉스
주가랑 OPM을 비교해 보면 OPM의
피크가 28년 중반 내에 나왔는데
이미 하이닉스는 고점 찍고 오른쪽
어깨까지 빠져 있는 상황이었거든요.
그래서이 부분은 이때 제가 알기로
데이터 센터 추작이었고 아마존의
오더컷과 금리 인상 이런게 같이
반영이 됐던 시기로 알고 있는데요.
그래서 오피 마지는 2018년 중반에
나왔는 나왔지만 그전에 이미 꺾일
거라고 투사들이 예상을 했고 뭐
컨센은 이미 떨어지기 시작했겠죠.
그다음 해나 뭐 다다음 봉지 그래서
주가는 어 미리 선행해서 빠졌었다.
그래서 이것도 좀 보면서 느꼈던 거
OPM 피크를 예상을 명확 잘할 수
있냐? 그게 문제인 거잖아요. 그
피크를 정확히 집어내야 어떻게
유의미하게 쓸 수가 있는데 이태용건도
여기 OPM 피크가 좀 더
유의했다라고 과거 데이터를 보면서
말씀은 하셨지만
여기서 또 코멘트 나온게 앞으로 익률
전망이 어떻게 변하는지라고 하잖아요.
4분기. 지금 컨센 기준으로 4분기가
5 OPM의 피크인데 그것만 믿고
4분기에 가서 팔아야지 하면은 늦거나
아니면 이익률이 또 내년에
올라간다라고 보면 또 틀릴 수도 있는
부분이기 때문에
>> 좀 어려운 거 같습니다. 과거
사이클과도 지금 사이클은 좀 다르기도
하고. 그리고 HBM이라는게
가격 협상이 이제 곧 나올 건데
내년에 100% 뭐 많게는 150%
이렇게 올라가게 되면 내년에 OPM이
안 꺾일 수도 있는 거잖아요. 오히려
조금씩 올라갈 수도 있고. 그 밑에
기저에 무조건 깔려야 되는게 빅테크의
케펙스 투자는 감소하면 안 된다.
둔화되면 안 된다. 그게 또 깔려
있어서 이런 부분이 좀 어려운 거
같습니다.
내일은 아 내일은 토요일이니까
다음 주 월요일 날 모닝 브리퍼할
때는 여기다가
>> 네.
>> 그 모건 스탠니의 반도체 겨울
온다라고 했던 과거 리포트
>> 네.
>> 예. 그 리포트가 언제 나왔었는지
>> 표시를 한번 해 주면
그것도 괜찮을 것 같아요. 리포트가
나왔던게
어 20
1년도
잠깐 21년도에
한번 나왔고
24년 8월에 나왔고
그리고 2017년 11월인가에
걸 기억을 하고 그러니까 모관
스탠리는요
어느
주가 수준에서 에서 반도체 겨울이
온다고 했는가? 네. 딱딱 찍어 주는
거죠. 알겠습니다.
>> 좋을 거 같아요.
나름대로 그 모건 스탠덴가 보면
황상일에게이
싸움으로 따지면
>> 싸움할 때 그런 말이 있거든. 선빵
>> 선빵인가요?
[웃음]
선빵 때디면 일당 50%
>> 아네
[웃음] 선빵 필승 그런 말이
있구나. 네. 어,
[웃음]
요게
[목을 가다듬음] 스탠지 메모리
반도체 시장 반응이었거든요.
>> 예.
>> 그 언제 나왔는지 한번 얘기해
주세요.
>> 예. 24년 5월엔 나왔고
나왔었습니다.
>> 예.
>> 그러니까 매도 리포트는 언제 나온
거예요?
>> 네. 아, 매도 리포트요? 어 24년
9월에
>> 그렇죠. 24년 9월에 나왔고 예
>> 그 전에 그 전에 어 민토이스 커밍이
21년 8월에 나왔습니다.
>> 21년 8월에 나와서
그랬고
>> 예 그리고 22년에도
침체 장기와 메모리 다운 사이클 해
가지고 나왔고요.음
>> 선빵은 21년 8월에 선빵 날렸던
거고요.
>> 선빵. 예.
그러고 나서 여기 차트에도 나오지만
21년 9월까지
주가 저렇게 박살해 놓고 난 다음에
그다음에 주가가 가파르게 올라가요.
또 [웃음]
그래서 21년 12월 22년 1월에는
마이크론 같은 경우에는 오히려
신고가고 하이닉스는
14만 원 정도까지 반등에 거쳤고
삼성전자 이제 8만 원 정도 반등에
거쳤고
[목을 가다듬음] 그랬었는데
아무튼 그 과거에도 보면 몇 번 더
있거든요.
표시해 가지고 한번 얘기해 주시고음
일단 그다음 리포트 한번 보겠습니다.
LG 엔솔네
>> 엔솔도 최근에 실적이 나왔는데요.
어닝 숫자 자체로는 어닝 쇼크를
발표를 했었거든요. 전자 실적 날에
나왔던 걸로 알고 있는데
>> 전 좀 내용을 살펴보겠습니다. 하반기
회복세가 지속될 것이다라고 하는데요.
어쨌든 이번에 흑자 전환을 했거든요.
그래서 회복하는 모습은 나타났습니다.
2분기 실적이 어 3개분기만의 영업
액자 전환을 했는데 잠정 실적 기준
매출 7.6조 조 영업이익 1133억
나왔습니다. 영업 이익 컨센이 한
1880억 정도였는데 어쨌든 컨센을
좀 크게 미달하는 숫자가 나왔고요.
얼티엄 셀즈 가동 중단 영향이 지속이
됐는데 S와 테슬레아 원형전지 출화
증가로 매출은 전분기 대비
증가했다라고 합니다. 영업 이익률은
1.5% 정도 나오면서 전분기
적자에서 좀 탈피하는 모습이
나타났고요. 영업비 컨센과 하나 증권
추정치를 크게 하여 한 이유는 당초
2분기 반영 예정이었던 북미 JV
보상금 수치가 3분기로 위연됐기
때문으로 추정을 한다라고 하고요.이
얼티엄 셀즈 쪽 이야기데 어 여기서
제가 알기 얼티엄셀 GM이랑 하는
거였는데
이게 공장이 멈추거나 주문이 취소되면
보상금이 좀 일고 있다라고
하더라고요. 그래서 그런 부분이
수치될 걸로 2분기 때 예상을 했는데
그게 3분기로 이연이 됐다고 합니다.
그래서 컨센을 좀 비싸하는 요인으로
작용을 했다라고 하고 여기에 관세한급
비용 약 1천억 정도 반영을 해 보면
어 보상금 이연 외에도 고정비 부담
증가 등 추가 비용 이슈가 이번
분기에도 좀 지속된게 아니냐라는
의견이고요. ESS 출화 증가
영향으로 미국 AMPC는 전문기 대비
27% 증가한 2,400억을 기록을
했고 배터리 생산량 기준 약
4.6GW 수준이라고 합니다.
AMPC 포함 영업 이익률을 세 개
분기만에 플러스 전환에 성공을
했다라고 하고 AMPC 재외 영업
이익률도 세 개 분기 연속 개선세를
보이고 있다라고 합니다. 하반기
전기차 배터리 추화 회복이 나타날
것으로 보고 있다 하는데요. 25년
EV 배터리 셀 생산은 전기차 약
30만대 분량으로 현재 추정을 하고
있고 25년부터
어 2분기까지 GM 전기차 누적
반면이 약 23만대 추정돼서 고객산의
배터리 제공은 약 7만대 수준 남아
있는 것으로 판단한다고 합니다. 현재
GM 월평균이 판매가 1만대 수준인
점을 감안해 보면 어 3분기 이후
재고가 상당 부분 소진되고 4분기에는
얼티엄 셀즈 가동이 본격 재개될
전망이라고 합니다. 어, ESS 추화
증가세가 이어지는 가운데 EV 추화도
회복되면서 매출 정장이나 AMPC
수치 규모도 점진적으로 커지지
않을까라는 의견입니다. 그래서이
얼티엄 셀즈가 올해 1월 달에 공장이
멈춘 걸로 알고 있거든요. 그게
아직까지
돌아가고 있지 않습니다. 어, 과매도
구간 진입 비중 확대를 공고한다라고
하는데요. S는 산업 특성상 하반기로
갈수록 프로젝트 발주가 집중되는
현상이 있다라고 하고요. 그렇기
때문에 추화 증간세가 하반기로 가면서
나타날 거다. 어 재생 재생 에너지
확대와 AI 데이터 센터 중심 전력
수요 증가에 따른 투자 확대도
중장기적인 수요를 뒷파침할 것으로
보고 있고요. 5월 LG 엔솔의 유럽
EV 배터리 출하는 Y와Y 22%
증가하면서 3개월 연속 20% 이상
성장을 예상하고 있습니다. 어,
테슬라 유럽 판매 호조나 GM
리스토킹 수요를 감안해 보면 하반기
EV 배터리 추라도 점신적으로 회복될
가능성이 높다라고 하고요. S나 EV
모두 추하 증가가 기대되는 가운데
현재 시가 총액은 70조원 중반까지
하락하면서 28년 예상 지배주기준
PR 24배 수준에서 거래 중이라고
합니다. 타겟 시가 총액 124조원
대비 현재 주가는 과매도 국면으로
보고 있고요. 테슬라 추화 증가나
하반기 GM량 추화 회복, ESS
추화 확대 및 수익성 개선을 감안해
보면 현 구간은 비중 확대 유효하다.
아래로 내려가서 보면
어이
자료는 메리치 증권한 자료인데요.
배터리 기업별 가동률 추인데
1분기까지만 나옵니다. 올해 1분기
CAT이맨 꼭대기에 있는데요.
가동률이
103%면 풀케파 이상으로 돌리고
있다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요. 그리고
SDI가 그다음을 이어가는데 SDI가
65% 정도의 가동률 현재 보이고
있습니다. 그리고 SK5는 맨 아래
정도 수준이고 그 중간이 LG 에너지
솔루션인데 47% 가동률로 돌아가고
있고요. 물론 LG 에노이 솔루션이
SDI 대비로 캐퍼 확장을 좀
과감하게 했기 때문에 업항이 좀
도라도이 가동률 회복 자체는 좀 더
시간이 걸리는 거는 뭐 당연한
이야기인 거 같긴 한데요. 또이
고객사의 특징들도 좀 있는 거
같아요. 그 LG 엔솔은 좀 더 북미
고객사 위주로 많이 되어 있고
GM이나 뭐 테슬라 이런 기업들이고
또 SDI는 유럽 노출도가 상대적으로
좀 더 높잖아요. 지금 유럽시 유럽의
전기차 시장은 나쁘지 않고 미국의
전기차 시장은 지난해 4분기 전기차
보조은 폐지하면서 좀 하향 추세에
있기 때문에 그런 부분이 이런
가동률로 드러나고 있는게 아닌가 그런
생각이 들고요. 오른쪽은 배터리 셀
기업들의 멀티플 테이블인데
LG노이 솔루션은 뭐 올해까지는 적자
전망이 되고 있기 때문에 PR이
계산이 되진 않고요. 내년에 이익이
난다라고 가정을 하고 보면 44배에
현재 거래가 되고 있는 거 같고 3
STI 기준으로는 한 26배 정도
거래되고 있는 거 같습니다. 아래
내려가서 뭐 글로벌 경쟁사로 보면
파나소닉이 22배고요. CATL이
14배, 뭐 BR이 15배 정도 되는
상황이라서 이익 증가나 그리고 글로벌
점유 이런 걸 봤을 때 CATL이
압도적인게 사실인데
CATL조차도 PR 밸류가 지금 높게
거래되고 있지 않거든요. 근데
뭐 어떤 투자자들은 CATL이
포워드로 14배인데 예를 들어 에너지
솔루션이 턴라운드 할 거니까 44배
그래도 그건 좀 비싼 거 아니야라고
좀 [콧방귀] 부정적으로 보시는
분들도 있을 것 같긴 한데
사실 쌌던 적은 없었던 거 같거든요.
우리나라 배터리 기업들이. 그래서
그런 부분은 좀 감안하고 보면
턴라운드 관점으로 접근하거나 다양성을
보고 접근하는게 좀 더 유미하지
않나? 근데 금리 어쨌든 고밸류기
때문에 지금 자동차도 로봇이 붙어
있고 배터리도 뭐나 향후에 로봇까지
생각하는 투자들이 상반기대 들어오면서
주가가 한번 펌핑이 나왔었잖아요.데
지금 금리가 올라가거나 채권 금리가
불안하게 되면 배터리나 뭐 자동차
이렇게고 밸류인 업종은 좀 위험할
수도 있겠다라는 생각은 듭니다.
박사는 어떻게 생각해?
그 아침에 자료 좀 제가 그 시티어도
같이 준비했잖아요. 아침에 자료. 그
투자 폰츠는이
배터리 셀 때문에 그 거 받을 수
없다고 그렇게 얘기했어요. 왜냐면
가격은 계속 내려가고 있습니다.
ASP ASP 중에 보면은 이차 정지
ESP도 내려가고 ASP도 내려가고
ES 그 ASP도 내려가고 있는 추세
계속 낮을 거예요. ASP
>> 다만 그 패키지 솔로션으로 돼야
되고요.
>> 이거 소피스까지 가야 된다.
셀 파는 거 아니고 셀 서비스까지
이건 뭐가 뭐 나중에
뭐 버수가 다 하고 커버하고 그래서
마진율로 우라할 수 있다고
생각하고요.
핵심 포인트는 ES 시전이요. 2차
전지 말고네 맞아요. ES 시전은
완전 그냥 2차 정지보다는 그냥
비슷하는 수준 가지고 우리 알 수
있어요. 예도처럼 뭐 CT는 지문
400조잖아요. S에서 2030까지는
가면은 또 거의 400조 정도 나올
수 있어요. 그러면 합쳐서는 800조
정도 돼요. 그 CT 기준하면
지금은이 정색을 할 수 있는 나라는
이거 두 나라밖에 없잖아요. 이거
중구는 중후중후하고 한하고 중구
내에서도 구조 하고 있어요.
>> 왜냐면 지금 ES 시점 보면은 CT
지금 차지할 비중는 20% 정도밖에
없어요. [목을 가다듬음] 밑에
조금만 30% 자지하고 있어요.
30% 조금만 좀 파산 되고 구조는
되면이 차업 구조는이 정체 업화는 또
좋아질 수 있어요. ES 측으로는 뭐
아마 다음
그 뭐 2, 3년 승전면 될 수 있는
연도를 보고 있어요.
>> 2040명까지.
>> 음. 왜냐면 처음으로 CT 지난번
컨테어요. 그 데이터 센터는 이키가
왔으면 얼마 정도 쓰는지
제시했잖아요. 아마 그쪽은 단어
회자는 다 이쪽으로 가는 방향으로
정했어요. 그래서 우리는 또 ES
시장 좀 잘 봐야 한다고 생각해요.이
시장 커지면서는 충부 CT들 혼자
톡시 하지 못했다고 생각하고요. 맥스
하면은 40% 가져갈 수 있어요.
맥스 그럼 나머지 60% 누가
가져가는지 좀 잘 봐야 합니다.
자,이 표범에서 음, 두 가지 생각이
드는데요.
자, 배터리 기업별 가동률 추위에서이
업항이 우리가 느끼는 업항은 되게 안
좋잖아요.
겨우 뭐 적자나고 있고 내년 돼야
흑자하는 걸 바라보고 있는 그런
상황에서
겨우 AMC 미국에서 주는 보조금
가지고
많이 이러고 있는 상황에서 돈이 안
되니까 가동률 37% 47% 55%
요러고 있는데 CATL은 103%
가족률 그죠
엄청난 호황입니다.
그래서 중국은 중국 캐 캡티브 마켓이
워낙 지금 전 세계에서 전기차 성장이
가장 강한 나라 있다 보니까 예수
시장 규모도 크고 거기 플러스도 해야
되고 나름대로
그러면서 103%의
가동열이 나오고 있고 지금 벌써
CATR하고
BID 두 개 합쳐서이 배터리 시장
점유율이 거의 60%예요. 맞습니다.
예. 그 LG솔이 옛날에
세계 넘버 원이었는데
>> 지금 한 8.8%밖에 안 되고
>> 예.
점유율이
그런데 그 점유율이 더 넓아질려면
가동률이 뭐 100% 되면서 막 해야
되는데 CAT은 저렇게 풀케파로
돌리고 있는 그리고 팔아먹을 수 있고
이익도 많이 나
>> 그런 상황에서 우리가 투자할 때
산업의 성장성이 아니라이 경쟁 구도를
보면서 투자해야 된다. 그 워론법의
말씀처럼
이게 보면 어 시장 성장만 보고 너무
광분했었잖아.
결국은 그 경쟁부도에서
CAT에 대해이 존재를 계속 어
평화했던 그런 부분이
투자는 냉정한 거니까 혹독한 대가
>> 그렇죠. 그렇습니다.
>> 돌아오는 거.
>> 예.
자, 그런 상황이고
어 한편으로는 이제 긍정적이면은
C테에 저렇게 103% 가동이
들어가기 때문에
우리 왕박사가 얘기한 것처럼
비중화권에
있어서의 ESS는 당연히 고성하고
있고 테슬라의 전기차 판매도 보면
최근에 돌고 있기 때문에 약간 이제
전기차 판매도 쾌점에서 벗어나는 그런
모습이 나오고
그랬을 때 CAT이 풀캡하기 때문에
어 뭐 유럽이든 미국이든 다른
나라에서의
이s기차에
들어가는 부분은 뭐 우리나라 기업밖에
안 남아 있으니까 그죠. 중국하고
우리나라데
>> 그러면 어 턴라운드 변곡점 최악의
국매은 지났다.
>> 최악의 국면 지난 건 맞죠? 맞아요.
전부 다 훨씬 더 나왔어요. 왜냐면
그
>> 2, 3년 전에 배터리 만든 홀사는
100에 넘어갔어요. 궁해서 조금만
밑에 가고 조금만 회사 다 배터리에
승산하겠다고 얘기하는데 개가
넘어갔다고 100에 100개 이상
넘어갔어요. 거의 다 파되었어요.
>> 아, 다 파.
>> 네. 그러니까 구조 조정이 확실하게
이루어졌고 그다음에 이제 턴라운드가
집약되는
국면인데
다행히 CATL이 풀캐파로 돌아가고
있어서
그 부분은 좀 긍정적이다 요런 생각이
좀 들었습니다. 그런데 투자자들이
2차전지 쪽에 대해서 좀 공격적으로
투자하려면 지금까지는 계속 숫자가
24년 25년 26년 계속 뭐 이제
돌아섰나 돌아섰나 했는데 안
돌아섰잖아. 그죠?
옛날에 그 아모리 퍼시픽도 계속
>> 어 돌아설 거야 썰 거야 했는데 계속
중국 쪽에서
적자가 계속 나왔던 것처럼이 숫자에
대한 믿음이 없어진 것
그 숫자에 대한 믿음을 보여 주려면
어 그러면이 분기별로 어닝
서프라이즈가 이제 한번 나야 되는데
아직까지는 지금 이번에도 쇼크단
말이죠.
어쨌든 나온 숫자로 보면 쇼크고 아까
말씀드린
얼티엄 셀즈 부분에서 수치한 부분이
이연이 된게 들어왔다면 이렇게까지
쇼크는 아니었을 거긴 합니다.
그래서 더늘 말씀드리지만 공감은 빨리
하야 돼. 실내는 천천히
애널리스트 드릴 이분들도 다 열심히
하고 그리고 애널리스트분들은
23년에도 계속 어 경고를 하긴
했었습니다. 조심해야 된다
>> 하셔 가지고
그런데 어 신앙에서 이제 어 너무
이제 광분하면서
바람 잠 그런 얘기를 할 때는 좀
의심하고 봐야 된다.
전화하게 됩니다.
자, 어, 리포트 다 봤고요. 아까
반도체 쪽만 조금 더 올라가면
어,
참 어려워요. 그죠?요 OPM 하고.
근데 저희 나름대로는 지금 한 두
가지를 보고 있는데 일단 OPM이
모든 산업에서 OPM이 증가할 때는
일단은 괜찮아요. 그죠? 오피마진이
계속 증가하는 구간에서는
>> 괜찮아요.
>> 예.
>> 근데 2018년도에는 미중무 무역
분쟁이 약이됐던 해였었죠.
2018년도에 [목을 가다듬음]
3월부터 붉어지기 시작했고 그때
트럼프 대통령이 1년 1기 2년
차였었는데 [목을 가다듬음] 그러고
나서 2018년 7월 5일인가의 첫
관세판
중국에다가 부여를 아마 했을 거예요.
예. 그런 부분들이 센티멘트를
악화시키는 그런 부분이 있었기 때문에
그게 아마 주가에도 영향을 좀 줬을
겁니다. 이게 반도체만
보면 어 OPM 56% 나오는데 왜
주가가 미리 꺾였지? 꺾였지? 예.
요렇게 봐
2018년 때 5월 달에 고점이
나왔다라고 돼 있잖아요.
>> 근데
7월 5일 날이 폭탄 관세를 갖다가
미사일 발사를 한거나 마찬가지게
되전에 좀 센티멘트가 약해지면서
빠지는 모습이 니다. 아까 24년
9월 달 같은 경우에도 반도체
겨울다는 리포트가 나왔지만 24년
8월에 엔트레이드 청사 그 쇼크가
8월 초에 있었잖아요.
>> 네. [목을 가다듬음]
그러면서 어 시장이 미리 반도체
주가도 그때 미리 좀 빠지는 것도
있었고
그리고 24년도는 미국 대통령 선거가
있었다는 냈는데이 대통령 선거에
있어서 2016년에도 그랬고
2024년에도 그랬고 트럼프 대통령이
당선되기 전에 어 워낙 이제 선거
과정에서이
보무역 얘기를 많이 했기 때문에
주가가 가 미리 빠지는 그런 병향이
좀 있었거든요.
거기다가 어 반도체 개울 리포트
나오면서
안 그래도 좀 시장 분위기가 어
센티먼트가 불안한데
겨울 얘기까지 나오면서
주가가 좀 큰 폭으로
>> 그래서요 OPM이랑요 차트에 플러스
그때 시장 상황은 어땠나? 예.
어땠나? 요렇게 좀 같이 봐야이
주가의 움직임이 좀 해석이 될
거다라고 생각합니다.
2018년은 조금 다른 봐야 되는
것도 하나가 있는 게
>> 2017년도 9월 10월 달서부터
현물 가격이 계속 빠지거든요. 이게
2020년까지도 이제 계속 빠지게
되는데 오히려 그때 나타났던 현상이
그 2018년도 3분기 때 물론 영업
이익률 피크를 치긴 했지만
2017년도 9월 10월 달에서부터
현물 가격이 계속 빠지면서 오히려
현물 가격이 계약 가격보다도 아래에
위치하게 되는 현상이 발생했었거든요.
그러면서 이제 어 주가도 미리
영업률에 선행해서 빠지는 모습이
나타나지 않았었나라고 좀 생각합니다.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 저희가 지금 두 개 보는데
하나가 이제 OPM이 어 언제 고점을
지느냐. 두 번째가이
선부 매니저가 얘기해 줬던 스파이스가
고정거래 가격을 이제 깨고 내려갈 때
스파프라이스가 고정 거래 가격보다 저
위에 있으면 계속 고정 거래 가격이
계속 올라가면서 그죠. 고정 거래
가격이 올라가니까 애널리스트는 당연히
어 이번에 고정 거래 가격
올라갔으니까 다음 분기 실적 좋게
나올 거예요. 그 고정 거래 가격이
계속 내년까지 이어진다라고 가정을
했을 때이 추정을 또 바꿔 놓고 근데
스퍼 프라이스가 스물스물 빠지면서
그죠.
데드 크로스가 나올 때
그때가 보니까 어
주식을 좀 줄여야 되는 그런
타이밍으로 저희도 보고 있는데 지금
랜드 쪽은 파프라이스가 고정 거래
가격보다 밑에 있다라고 이렇게 몇 번
나오던데 맞아요? 랜드는
아니에요. 어.
>> 아, 최근 지표에서는 좀 밑으로
갔다가 왔다 갔다 하고 있는 걸로
보이고 있습니다.
>> 요번에 우리가
만들어 준 자료인가? 거기 어디 그
캡처 연구
디램은 위에 있고 랜드는 밑에 있고
뭐 그런 식으로 되겠던 거 같아.
>> 예. 근데 그 흐름상으로 그렇게
보이는 건데 이제
까처럼 흐름만 보면 그렇게 보이는
건데 아직은 이제 고정 거래 가격
자체는 랜드나 드랩이나 고정 거래
가격이 두 배 정도 쌉니다. 그니까
스파크 가격이 두 배 정도 비쌉니다.
>> 어 두 배나 더 비싸요?네
>> 아직까지는 그래요.
>> 어 그래요? 예. 근데 흐름상에서는
스팟 가격이 먼저 조금씩 내려오는
느낌이 들죠.
>> 스팟 가격은 그리고 램쪽 아직까지 저
위에 있는데
>> 스팟 가격도 지금까지는 보면 계속
올랐잖아요. 수출
>> 네네.
>> 동양에 다 나오잖아. 보면
>> 월별네. 1 가격하고 뭐 DDR4,
DDR5 뭐 다 나오는데 지금
아직까지는 계속 올라가고 있어요.
올라가는 흐름이 이제 약간 둔화되는
거 같기 때문에
>> 네.
>> 기 쪽은 계속 올라가고 있고 랜드
쪽은 약간 마찰이 있는 상황이고
>> 그런데 이제 조금 다르게 봐 수 있는
건 스팟 가격이라는 거는 이제 B2C
시장 그니까 비즈니스투 커스터머 우리
소비자 시장이거든요. 저희가 용산에서
살 수 있는 거. 요게 스
가격이에요. 그래서 서버 쪽이랑은
약간 그 느낌이 좀 다를 거라고
생각하고 있습니다. 서버 좀비
B2비즈니스투 비즈니스 시장에서
사자들끼리
거래하는 시장이어서 완전 비공개
시장입니다. 그리고 PC용이 아니고
AI 서버용 용도 다르고 그래서 요즘
거래 고정 거래 가격으로 좀 나오는
것들은 이제 어 서버 중심으로 좀
나온다고 보시면 될 거 같아요.
그
>> 용산 가격 이런 거는 찾아보면 다
나오더라고.
>> 그거 참고를 해.
>> 그게 이제 인덱스화 되면 이제 스탁이
되는 거고 그냥 찾아보면 지금도
나옵니다.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 예.
모은게 이제 인덱스카게
>> 음
>> 대만 것까지야 영상뿐만 아니에
>> 용산뿐만 아니라
>> 대만까지 중국까지
>> 아직까지는이 디램이나 랜드 스파
가격이 어 고정가 가격보다는 저 위에
있다고 합니다. 저 위에 있으니까 그
데드 크로스가 나오려면 시간이 좀
걸리겠네.
>> 예.
그리고 스팟 가격이 지금 뭐 급락할
이유는 없잖아 사실.
>> 아, 지금 서버에서 다 가져가 가지고
물량이 유통 시장에서 별로 없어요.
그래서
>> 지금 오히려 너무 없어서 하드웨어
성능을 그 업그레이드를 조금 버디게
하는 경향도 있어요. 없어 가지고
비싸기도 하고.
>> 그러고 보니까이 별주 버전 끝나고이
복부장하고
얘기를 할 때 복부장이 그런 얘기를
했던 거 같아.
그 노트북을 조립해서 자기 조한테
노트북을 조립해서 만들어 주려고 좀
알아봤더니 스파 가격이 너무 비싸
가지고 조립해서 만드는게 옛날에는
조립해서 만들면 어 훨씬 쌌잖아.
>> 삼성이나 LG 노트북 시키면 300만
원이대 노트북이 아니라 PC겠죠?
>> 300만 원이면 용산에서 이렇게 사
가지고 조립하면 한 200 되나?
>> 예. 저도 뭐 조립 예전에 한 친구들
거 제가 다 해 줬거든요. 매집대
조립했는데
>> 보통 한 100만 원이면 초반 때면은
웬만 쓸 만하게 나오고 GPU
게임용으로 강하게 해도 한 150만
원 100만 후반되면 가능하거든요.
지금은 이제 업도부터 안 되는
가격이죠. 300원
>> 그러니까 그 얘기를 하더라고.
그러면서 아 그냥이 사서서는게 낫다고
그냥 LG 삼성 사라 그러더라고.
예. 그런 것만 하더라도
>> 아직까지 스팟 가격이거죠.
>> 예. 거기는 사실 BTB 시장이라서
더 더 쌀 수도 있어요. 어떻게 보면
>> 메모리가
>> 그러니까 미리 확보하 메모리
>> 도매 가격이잖아요. 메모리가
>> 자 그렇다고 합니다. 예.
>> 자 우리나라 시장 어떻게
시작했습니까?네 네. 어, 플러스
3.57%로 상승해서 출발했고요.
현재 3.05%로 속공 하락하고
있습니다. 네.
어제 양간 선물이 4.56 정도로
시작했기 때문에 거기서 한 20%
30% 낮은 각에서 항상 시작하더라고
보니까. 네.
>> 3.5. 어제도이 언저리에서
시작했었잖아요.
그죠?
>> 맞습니다. 음.
그리고 어제 옵션 만기일이었는데 막
변동성 엄청 심했어요.
>> 예.
>> 그리고 코스닥은 어떻게 되겠어요?
>> 네. 코스닥 1.64% 상승해서
출발했고요. 현재 0.8%
플러스입니다.
네. 서포락 하고 있습니다. 네.
코스닥도 어제
장중에는 뭐 3%는게 올라가는 모습이
나오다가
>> 심이 부족하면서 좀 밀리는 그런
모습이 나오고 어제 동양도 보면
외국인은
주식 다 샀어요. 그죠? 선물도 사고
다 했는데 개인 투자자들의 매도가
보통 이렇게 많이 빠지면 오히려
하는데 최근에 아직까지 신용 전체적인
장보는 뭐 별로 안 빠졌다
그러더라고. 안 빠졌는데 그것도 약간
신용 시장도 우리가 좀 아셔야 되는게
브닉이
좀 있어요.
>> 음.
>> 그래서 돈많은 진짜 슈퍼 개미들이
있잖아요.
>> 예. 그런 선수다는 잘 안
걸리더라고.
>> 음.
>> 근데 미리 좀 이래 줄이는 권원이
있어요.
>> 그렇죠.이
>> 좀 줄여 놨다가 어 돈다 싶으면 다시
또 확 들어가더라고.
>> 그리고 신용도이
그 지점이나 이런 데서 얼마나
오랫동안이
큰 고객일수록
그런 반대 매매 나올 때 뭐
지점하고이 내고가 좀 되는 거
같더라고.
신경이 그저께는 좀 놀랬던게 오히려
늘었더라고.
>> 그러니까
>> 네. 그래서 예 보니까 그 자료
관련된 미리스에서 자료가 나오긴
했었는데 원래 증거률이라고 하는게
보통 20% 정도 내외에서 이제
움직였었는데
>> 그거를 지난 지진한 달 지난달 어
대부분의 증권사들이 다 40%
이상으로 상향 조정을 해 가지고
>> 오히려 이런 전쟁이나 아니면은 올해
상반기 때 있었던 조정보다도 반대
매매가 다 안 틀리는 경량이
있었다라고 설명하는 자료가
있었습니다. 그걸 상향 조정을 해
버리면 담보율을 올렸기 때문에
>> 네.
>> 어 오히려 주식을 미리 좀
줄이든다든지 그 레버리지를 그만큼 덜
쓰게 되는 거잖아요.
>> 네. 그런 사전적인 좀 조치가 있었기
때문에 좀 충격이 덜했을 수도 있다.
그렇게도
자, 오늘 밤 미국 시장 어떻게
되는지 한번 보겠습니다. 어제 SP
500, 나스닥 필반 전부 다 플러스
날 거다. 예. 그렇게 전망을 해
주셨는데 다 맞았다. 그렇죠?
>> 예.
추천 프로
>> 어 전 오늘 밤도 상승 이어갈 것
같습니다.
>> 밤 상승은 예 SMP 500이죠?네
>> SMP 500
>> 장프로는 나스닥은 어떻게 돼요? 상승
>> 상승도
>> 상승 이어가고
필반 어제 확실히 이제 돌아서니까
필반이 제일 강하게 돌아서
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 뭐 SP 500 나수닥 다 상승하는데
필반 마이너스 날리는 없잖아요.
>> 예 그렇습니다. 일반도 뭐 계속해서
꾸역꾸역 좀 올라가지 않을까라고
생각을 하고 있고 오늘 SK 하이닉스
ADR이 상장이 됩니다.
그런 부분이
분위기를 조금 자우하지 않을까라는
생각입니다.
일반도 플러스.
자, 코스닥은
오늘도 뭐 음봉이에요. 네.
그 숙률이 많이 올라가겠어.
>> 어제 틀렸어요. 어제 어제는 제가
>> 어제는 틀렸고네
>> 어제 틀렸어요.
>> 호스닥 음봉이었는데 어제
양봉이었어요.네
>> 양봉이었습니다.
>> 근데 오늘도 음봉이란 말이죠.네
>> 음봉은 나왔습니다.
>> 시스템은 뭐 냉정한 거니까 그죠? 실
나오는 대로 얘기하는 거잖아. 그죠?
그다음에 코스피는 어제
양봉난다고 했었는데 셨습니다.
기분 좋게 올라가다가 점심 시간 되좀
확 빠졌다가
아
오늘 시초가 좀 높게 시작을 하긴
했고 시초가 이제 반도체가 주도하면서
올랐는데 오늘은 반도체가 윗꼬리 달고
내려오면서 다섹터가 다 올라가는
움직임이
나오는 거 같아서
참 [콧방귀] 음봉의 기운이 좀 더
강하게 느껴
>> 오늘.
>> 네.
>> 금요 아 또 그것도 있나?
>> 그 그죠.
문봉이라고.
자 주요 종목들 동량 하이닉스는
어떻게 되고 있어요?네 네. 하이닉스
현재 1.9%
상승하고 있는데요.
>> 어, 시초가가 좀 높게 시작한 걸로
제가 아까 봤었는데 한
>> 4%를 시작했네.
>> 4%로 시작했는데 지금 밀리고
있고요.
>> 그리고 삼성전자는 2.8%인데 어
시초가 2.5% 정도로 어, 시작을
했었고 고가가 5%까지 올랐었어요.
>> 최근에 좀 빠 지금 좀 빠지고 있는
그런 상황이고 시장을 보니까요. 현재
외국인이 또 4,억 가까이 팔고
있어요.
>> 어.
>> 음. 여전히 전체 거래소시장에서
>> 네. 거래소 시장에서 전체적으로
외국인들이 4,억을 팔고 있다라는
얘기는 아무래도 뭐 삼성전자나
하이닉스 매도가 또 나오고 있는게
아닌가라고 생각이 되고요. 어 반대로
그 외에 있는 다른 타세타들이
지금 전반적으로 다가갑니다. 에,
증권주도 다 4%대 이상 올라가고
있고 그동안 계속 약했던 2차전지도
오늘 한 5%대 올라가고 있고 그동안
계속 하락했던 유통주들도 이제다고
있고
타섹타들이네 반도체를 제외한 그런
쪽의 상승세가 오늘은 조금 더 큰 거
같습니다.
시장이 2.88% 88% 올라가면서
7,500
러고 있다. 그죠?
아, 그 어제 한 2주 전에 저희
회사에 이름을 하신 분이 찾아오셨는데
좀 안타까운게
그
이주에 왔을 때 오셨을 때 어 계속
아 지금 7월 장인 어 분위기가 여러
가지 이제 암초들이 있잖아요.
이 그런 암초들 얘기하고 어
단기적으로 좀 과열된 모습 뭐 이런
걸 얘기하면서 그 50%만 저희가
최근에 들어오신 분들은 50%만 먼저
진입을 했는데 왜 그 50%를
분할해서 안 샀냐고
>> 그런 얘기를 하길래
>> 첫 질문이 그래서 그러면 몇 퍼센트씩
샀어야 되냐고
그러고 아니 그리고 50% 사놓고
우리가 또 어제 거저게 시장에이
정도면 가격이면 어 제가 이번 달
전망 7,50으로 적어놨잖아요.
>> 예 그렇습니다.
>> 그래서 어 7,500m에서는
들어가면 먹는 구간이니까 그래서 또
추가로 진입을 했는데 그분은 또 그
나머지 50% 현금을 빼
버렸었더라고.
현금을 빼 인출해 그런 거
>> 어 추가적으로 우리가 매수 들어갈
때는 또 매수가 못 들어가습니다.
그런 걸 다 해 놓고 [콧방귀]
뭐 그러니까
그래서 아까
그 댓글에도
믿음이 중요하다고
[웃음]
그런 분이 나는 실력이 없기 때문에
체쓸 일을 믿는 수밖에 없다고 그런
말씀는데
그런 일들이 있어서 저는 참
안타깝습니다. 그 제가
고객분들한테도 많이 그런 얘기를 하거
그동안에 한 4년 5년 주식을 해
보시고 아니면 뭐 20년 하신 분들도
있고
>> 음
>> 해보니까 안 돼서 찾아온 거잖아요.
그
>> 예
>> 안 돼서 찾아오고
>> 그리고
최근에 또 저희만큼 이렇게 소통을 해
주는 채널도 없잖아요. 운용사도 이게
불안할 때는 저희 뭐 일한 전쟁이
터졌던 그랬을 때 어떻게 자금이
운용될까
>> 예 그런 걸 갖다가 같이 모닝
브리퍼대에서 이때도 얘기하고 그다음에
웜의 심박에서도 다 얘기하거든
>> 그래서 우리 또 댓글에 아 웜박
코덱스 200 이번에 바닥에서
[목을 가다듬음] 샀어요. 아까도
그런 말씀 다 해 주셨는데
그런 소통까지도 다 하는데 그런
질문을 받으면
>> 예
>> 그래서
저님 그런데 제 경험상으로 고객들
이렇게 그
>> 직접 접촉해 보고 이제 대하는 대한
경험상을 보면은 아 그런 분들의
타입이 있더라고요. 어떤 타입이냐면은
3억이
노후 자금인데
>> 음 [목을 가다듬음]
>> 이걸 다 수식으로 해 놓으니까 네
>> 날마다 날마다 그 변동성에 굉장히
괴로워하시는 분들이 [목을 가다듬음]
>> 한 타입일 거 같아요. 예. 물론
성향상으로
>> 정확한 얘기
>> 그러면서
그런 질문에
그런
좀 딱 어 좀 안타깝잖아요. 그죠?
네. 그냥 믿겨 믿고 본인이 어떻게
보면 정말 주식으로 이래저래이
그동안에 한 4, 5년 이렇게
4년 전에도 우리 회사도 한번
찾아오고
>> 음
>> 그 계속 여기저기 이제 막 어
기웃거리지면서
본인이 해 보려고다가 되죠. 근데 그
얘기를 하는 거예요.
새슬리 입평에서는이 3억이 큰 돈이
아닌 것처럼 보이시겠지만 해서 제가
거의 30억이나 100억이나 그죠
200억이나
>> 다 동일하게 운영이 되고 오히려
그렇게 한 2, 3억만큼은 정말 제
노후 자금이니까음
>> 그런 마음을 저희가 알기 때문에
더더욱 더더욱 그런 분들을 더 컨택을
많이 하잖아요.
>> 그렇습니다. 저희한테 40억 맡겨서
지금 110억 된 고객 한 번도 만난
적이 없어요. 요번 또 연락 안 오고
벌써
>> 한 그분들이 한 7, 8년 되다
보니까
>> 그냥 연락도 없고 저희도 연락고
>> 이런애 한 번도 연락 안네
>> 그런데 오히려 이렇게 주식을 저희가
채슬리가 하나의 희망이기 때문에
찾아오시는 분들의 그 마음을 알기
때문에 오실 때마다 다 만나뵙고
또 질문 있으시면 또 어 2주 만에
더 찾아오시게 저번에 이주님도 오셨을
때 어 예전에 저 어 보신 적 있죠?
자녀도 오셨고 그런
부분들이 그렇게 좀 가까운데
그 믿음이 생기기 위해서는 한 6개월
그래서 제가 한 3개월에서 6개월
동안 어 아침에 모닝 브리프도
보시면서 꾸준히 한번 믿고 한번
지켜보셔
>> 그런 말씀을 드렸는데 그 마음도 저는
이해는 해요.
>> 그죠? 우리 최구 사장님 얘기처럼이
>> 마지막 작은 맞아. 뭐 손해 가다
하면 안 되니까.
>> 네. 그런 마음을 이해하는데
그 신뢰를 갖기 위해서도 노력은
필요하거든요.
>> 근데 저희 모닝 브리프나 저기 워맨
신방이나 이런 거는 또 안 보시는 거
같더라고요.
그래서 아침마다 그 원인 브리퍼도 좀
보시고 그렇게 했습니다.
아 내일은 또 즐거운 별주 부전이
있습니다. 별주부인에서는
소연철 박사님이 어제
>> 책 들고 오셨는데
>> 원래 소박사님이이 IT
애널리스트였잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 그래서 지난번에 그 한반도 대변화 어
얘기도 해 주셨고 어 이번에는이
기업들 쭉 해 가지고 정리한 책을
들고 오셨다고 그래서 제가
>> 바로 그 [콧방귀] 우리 별주부전에
좀 나오시라. 음
>> 나오셔 가지고 그 기업들 얘기 좀 해
달라고.
우리 별주전 초반에 있었을 때 뭐
CPU가 어떻게 되고 이런 거를 또
아주 자세하게 설명을 해 주셨던이
AI 박사
>> 예
>> 전문가 엘리 님이 영국 갔다고
오셨다고
>> 또 들린다고 하시더라고.
그래서 내일은 아주 또 고급진 그런
별주 부진이 될 거 같다는
생각입니다.
>> 네. 그러면 어 이번 한 주이
변동성심 한장에
>> 어 우리 체밀턴 분들 고생
많으셨습니다.
>> 예.
>> 원래 주식이라는 이런 겁니다.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 원래 주식이라는 예. 이런 거고
그래서 주식에
어 익숙하지 못하고 공부가 덜 돼
있고 단련되어 의지 못한 사람들이
함부로 쉽게 돈 못 벌게 만들려고
하는게이 변동성이라는 장치라는
다시 한번 기억하시면서
이번 한주 고생 많으셨는데 비도 많이
오고 그죠?
>> 예. 음.
>> 근데 저 비가 비 내릴 때는 뭐
어제는 천둥 번개 치고 하는데 비가
내 오고 나면 여의도 공원의 저들이
>> 얼마나 공기 도깨 그지 그죠.
지저분한 거 싹 쓸려 내려가고
>> 그러면서 저 수목들이 얼마나 파릇파릇
자릅니까?
저는 주식주 그냥 변동생이
그렇게 봐기 때문에이
변동생에 대한 공부를 아 이번에도 또
어 제대로 했다. 그렇게 생각하시면서
한 주 정리하시길 바라겠습니다.
>> 다 했죠?
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 체슬리 모닝 브리프 오늘 7월
10일 금요일 순서는 여기까지
하겠습니다. 함께해 주신 여러분
고맙습니다. 감사합니다.